comme toujours à des gens dans le
châtier chris noth bascule parce que ils
sont relou mais comment faire sans les
rôles ou fab s'il n'avait pas de rôle où
il y aurait plus grand monde sur terre
ce serait compliqué et femmes qui est là
qui va mettre le casque fab en
accélération fatale 15 pour le quai de
bondy ouais mais c'est juste pour le but
de la partie
t'es juste là haut je crois qu'il ya du
photographe la ja du photographe de
qualité je crois fab un accueil très
heureux nous il est heureux de tout
ça est une belle journée aujourd'hui
je me le set up en place pour pouvoir
les et ça en direct
avec la turbine
bah oui pas
d'hésitation à
aujourd'hui sur la partie on va suivre
la partie entre le meilleur et le moins
bon du tournoi jusqu'à maintenant
finalement
les réserves sur rhodia qui sait
peut-être bien remis un fa parce qu'il a
joué toute la nuit en boulettes bah oui
il va peut-être lui porter chance
bon façon
j'en ai besoin pour ce pour se remettre
à l'endroit pourquoi pas quoi donc petit
petrov on va voir si les reds à à une
trouvaille
dessus pour mettre en doute l époque
comme fabi avait su le faire un dessin
pour lui
on l'espère fab donkey la ilaha illallah
petrov attaque petites secondes je crois
que j'ai eu des mises à jour sur le
numéro de la partie qui a pas forcément
marcher
que je vais je vais tout de suite
ok là je le petit coup ces quatre bagues
aux cordes et toi avez joué je crois
déjà ce coût ces quatre
bons valide pas l'essai un des cinq si
simple noir c'est pas idiot un ouais bah
c'est pas con
c'est pas idiot on va y revenir
fab il me faut une toute petite minute
pedro soler je te laisse meublés non
rebond général et nord se développe
voilà si nos facs et c6
en épaulant valoir plus qu'un psychiatre
pour le prendre au dépourvu fera
vraiment une bonne idée quoi il a l'air
de connaître en tout cas on pourrait
creuser tout vous aider trois renvois le
cahier chez lui
partir c'est parti et partir un f6
les d4
normal on sut ont fui des partis pour
l'instant dont une bonne partie de max
la garde par exemple
ça allait donner quoi les perdu
mais je connais pas la partie je suis
pas sûr ce à cause de l'ouverture du
tout bonjour les dents et si je vous des
5 parce que finalement l'idée des blancs
c'est de faire des cinq eux-mêmes et de
prendre de l'espace donc tous les pions
de la dame encore une fois
je serai c'est très intéressant quand tu
fais d3 d4 d5 trois coups d'affilée
ça va être beau ça non vois tu fais un
petit train donc je m'attends à des
singles appartenait pour la il entre
ainsi de soutenir sa soeur kylie par
ippon psi
j'ai souvenir
on va voir s'il y arrive hein après
peut-être que d'autres sont possibles
géré comme j'ai jamais analysé la
position je peux pas trop vous dire mais
à priori pour moi des 5 est le coup le
plus
le plus logique ce que tu penses que le
fait d'avoir un beat c'est tout un buzz
de l'été toute la nuit ça va lui
apporter quelque chose alors après ce
début de partie là après les 4 5 minutes
de jeu et ce qui n'a pas l'air plus
tranquille finalement grâce à ces
boulettes
on va dire que ce que ça peut lui
apporter c'est juste que je pense qu'il
a acté le fait que la qualif finito way
et du coup il va jouer pour jouer donc
avec moins de pression et
et voilà qu'il fait fausse à deux
niveaux on finissait pas de descendre
que j'attendais
donc tu joue sans pression
après ce sens bien en mal à ça dépend
entre pas jouer en temps food rend non
plus complètement lundi arrive
oui mais je vais essayer
faut qu'il y arrive avec un minimum de
temps vie mais je pense qu'il va faire
sa partie va pas la balancer à la
poubelle quoi toi c'est beau quand on
est absolument rien à [ __ ] mais bon tu
crois mais j'en ai rien à [ __ ] c'est
chiant d'ailleurs je préfère un art
vraiment rien à [ __ ] aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe je préférais literally dong caire
camille karuk en fait il y en a vraiment
absolument rien à [ __ ] bon en fait
pour être enfin je sais pas combien je
m'en fous dans le fond mais quand je
joue il ya un truc qui me rattrape
malgré moi moi je veux m'en [ __ ]
mais tu y arrives pas salut c'est
peut-être l'un verse pas complètement on
va dire
mais as well et résa il a un peu aussi
envoyé peut-être balader toute la prépa
tout le côté un peu
d'avant-tournoi qui n'a pas du tout
marché a peut-être voulu non non de
revenir là c'est peut-être c'était bien
en réalité
oui et non en fait de normand c'est une
très mauvaise préparation de faire ça
rime était géré quand tu es dernier
après rongeront nous diront le contraire
n'est pas pour cette partie avec
peut-être pour l'après tournoi sert qui
va peut-être toutes ses dents riba
l'année
mais normalement au blitz et jusqu'à 6
heures du mat c'est archi d'être fiers
que fait dès mardi fin du tour dans
l'avion il appelle à oulad émir nito
finito valdimir krainik off ça dégage et
enfin de chasse était une bonne nouvelle
pour la presse ouais en fait peut-être
qu'il a déjà dégagé en fait les affaires
de buts je regarde ce que ce genre de
match il a
d'ailleurs intérêt ça on le voit ici
avec avec le drapeau français je crois
que sur il a joué sur leach s ouais et
l'information a été confirmée tout à
l'heure je suis pas les re vérifier mais
parce que des fois tu sais tu as le cash
dans l'ordinateur ou quoi mais je crois
que là bas il est encore sous drapeau
iranien où sa survie chess à israël a
toujours
faim ont fait un tour à pau d'internet
non mais je sais mais juste pour dire
quoi c'est sympa
un bel appareil photo on sent le match
de pro a et on voit bien ouais bah
hissbach
ce très beau qui est inclus dans un
appareil photo
a priori les quatre nouveautés et pas
beaucoup avec trois parties dont une
partie très intéressante entre avec son
1 continue que c'est une joueuse de
tennis
sablettes thann
c'est pas la même taille mais et 7
tonnes n'avait pas tenus contre
alexandra que son nom avait gagné la
partie en 38 coups elle avait joué fouet
deux avec son bras
dans cette position
catcheur si une prépa c'est une bonne
nouvelle ouais ou les lambeaux de belote
je connais pas je le camouflet au centre
parfait de réfléchir ai pas je suis en
train de vie tablette toute l'année on y
perd vitesse
c'est vous qui avez quelqu'un qui m'a
dit oui il a perdu le match d'hyper
violette mais il a dominé échiquéenne
mans mardi d' ski avec des coups très
fin enfin j'étais très rassuré
et variés jarrige c'est devenu tellement
conne à
l'époque une chaise vide un peu le
regard hagard
moi je la sens bien cette partie
c'est bien s'ils gagnent ce le jeu fera
du bien ça relance à deux plaintes la du
tournoi tout ça est ce qu'il ya des
matches où tu as l'air
aussi à 2m et humaniste et pas des blitz
oui mais oui je sorte à quoi si valises
et oui je marche faille voulu faire un
gros tournant à la boudeuse vinik
rachat par jour je me prépare bien je
dors bien bon il commence avec trois
défaites
c'est bon on va faire à la team aqua va
sortir le soufre en vrac fois
oui il enchaîne les victoires
comme soviétique terrain vierge
tu domines pas en terme d'échec en hyper
belette le belette et hyper belette
c'est juste un autre jeu oh bah oui mais
quand même là tu va décevoir maquis 83 à
dans le tchat attention aux l'hyper
belette c'est le jeu quand même mail
pour bakhit il a fait beaucoup de
progrès un bac y est on y perd 1,7 à
gijón en jouant belette mais je pense
qu'il peut progresser aussi en hyper
très bons joueurs de paul est un bas qui
cliquaient maintenant le sort des foyers
en tournant et tous les jours ils
cliquent vraiment avant le top 12 ou le
top 16 du club subaquatique voiture et
urban 6,83 à connecter côté rien je
clique
annoncé on sent qu'ils se rapprochent
plus de bas qui a petit à petit à lire
voir que cramique je vois jamais cliquer
nom
d'école hyper belette tu as 30 secondes
pour la partie c'est beau de l'etna une
minute mais un peu long c'est quand même
cadence grand-père madrigal ultra ball
est à ses côtés 15 c'est qu'un vrai
c'est magnifique l'ultra belette
15 secondes c'est vais pas te faire le
lit pire bête avec cette seconde main
d'autant plus qu'on attend une seconde
en fait il y avait un boulet tout avait
dix secondes plus une seconde de raju a
laissé beaucoup trop lent
raison d'orages ou mais que je veux dire
il peut y avoir le
jeu c'est pas un truc que j'avais bien
et j'ai jamais vu sur internet ces deux
systèmes balancier tu bouffes le ton
adversaire je glissais avec la ddt avec
ça tu conseilles de 10 secondes chacun
où je sais pas un truc comme ça
tu cliques qui est située à finir second
groupe 9 12 38 c samedi tu jouer vite
mais c'est vraiment comme ça qu'on
jouait dans le temps en temps il ya un
yacht saviez qu'elle eut renversé c'est
très tradition
fait partie longue et je vais bien je
vais bien je l'avais vu ailleurs enfin
vous n'avez classes ont joué même bravo
bonjour les 30 secondes
après 6,6 si tu as un bel [ __ ] que
vous vite le jury toxiques mais en fait
si joue tranquille il joue tranquille ça
assez marrant c'est ça s'autorégule un
peu
si tu cliques vite l'ouverture l'autre
qui évite aussi supplique tranquille il
expliquant même rythme quoi s'applique à
fond
les belettes d'hier soir de son petit
peuple d'un symptôme d'un braquage ce
total la barre des petits jeunes qui
pète un cable car il sait que ses
chances de gagner tant elles sont nulles
un peu aussi way façon qu'il le fasse ou
pas il va pas nier le temps d'un donc si
ça le détend autant qu'ils se détendre
alors est-ce que je dise à mathieu
jeu apparaît à partir d'un certain âge
où on 19 pour certains c'est déjà l'âge
mais tu te détends peut-être d'une autre
manière when a man général de fois tu
peux sortir quoi juste tu vas rencontrer
du monde tu veux un peu voir des coûts
chez ba au cinéma faire des trucs qu'on
sait très bien de quoi tu parles fab oui
mais pas que enfin non non c'est nous
sachons n'essaye pas de nous cacher tu
peux aller regarder des séries dans des
bas oui oui oui pour rencontrer des gens
aller au cinéma oui oui oui fab nous
avons compris nous sachons mais ça
peut-être tu le fais plus soit là bas
certains à 19 tu fais déjà fermé tu peux
voilà 20 21 22 mètres
juste pour souffler vous pour souffler
un petit peu fab
tu peux aller marcher faire un tour
de marché ont bien marché dans le centre
de madrid
mais
on ne peut pas avoir en iran et mais f1
il à madrid les flux environ la fin et
puis rien
mais s'il veut pas voir que je dis pas
qui doit voir juste deux mois j'aurais
pu mais front j'en connais un autre qui
a commenté avec une petite fille aurait
aussi fait et qui serait peut-être même
pas venu au jeu ce jour là très beau
conte ap la nouvelle entité serait en
train de dormir sur la table
le ton à des candidats fini taureau
mais oui
ça a été extraordinaire voyage auraient
été portés par les arbitres c'est aussi
ça aurait pu être extrait pour effet nul
parce qu'il s'en fout on fait de faire
nul
oui au blad il aurait fixé la nul la
veille l'orée des années poké si tu ne
fais pas nul je vais montrer je vais me
préparer à fond je te défonce mais si tu
fais est nul ça va ça va on peut fixer
maintenant et au moins la soirée
tranquille surtout qu'en plus values
aurait calculé qu'il avait qu'une seule
partie après qu'après les jours de repos
donc il peut il peut faire il peut
enchaîner
et pour un régime alimentaire spécifique
en compétition
pas sûr j'en serais en faute
non mais après je sais qu'il ya toute
une équipe avec des masseurs
non il est vraiment un très bon passeur
très réputé en russie mais il l'a viré
on sait pas ah bon il appelait non on
sait pas je crois donc on se demande s
il plaît bien qu avant ce tournoi est
apparemment ça marche bien peut-être eu
un autre master encore mieux
mais ouais non il a hélas toute une
équipe
mais c'est beaucoup il s'est fait bill
était la tronche veut ouais c'est moi
explique tout ça change des autres jours
mais en fait ça s'est enfin sans rigoler
je suis sûr que ça lui fait du bien je
suis sûr qu'il va beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui n'est pas vraiment pas de
bol
il a pris 10 nuls irène
en
puisqu'il a plongé à tacler appris à
lire et zakia de l'être la journée il va
juste celui qui que de la merde d'être
ça va faire tilt
non mais il avait vraiment un très bon
passeur ça c'est sûr dépôt
alors la joue apparemment elle fait 350
parties un finalement tout est pas jusqu
à 4h du matin et jusqu'à 5h 45
ça c'est vrai que c'est extraordinaire
moi je suis très heureux déjà tu me tues
demande vraiment si j'oublie aujourd'hui
qui demandera vraiment pourquoi ils ont
besoin du jour de repos en fait mais un
juge si creek quoi
et je crois atx scénario dit qu'il a
gagné narrow disent qu'ils commentent en
plus son vrai nom d'hergé s'est
interrogé est ce que c'est si bien
commenté
ben oui
268e pour être très précis ça je crois
que c'est contre
268 contre naro-1 spécifique ans et je
crois qu'ils appliquent aussi un peu à
côté
magnus qui était très heureux aussi sur
twitter johnny va très bien joué
aujourd'hui
c'est quoi la affecté par tina mais
c'est pas une rave en fait il a juste
vraiment passé sa nuit à faire des
belettes fins et pas une ride en fait
pas une blague déjà fort vote et une
info par on est très professionnel on
suit le monde des échecs on sait quoi
mais chez même pas si c'est une
préparation qu'il est en train de faire
là je pense pas enfin je crois qu'ils
cliquent au hasard
je crois qu'il y en a absolument rien à
[ __ ] c'est magnifique
c'est assez exceptionnel
en fait on va voir ce que ça dure mais
il peut finir la partie avec plusieurs
50 là aussi en fait je crois que quand
tu as joué tellement belette tata a
tu calcules qu'enfin un époux issue il
est pas bien
mais sans sens sans aucun second degré
je pense que c'est une très bonne chose
pour ali reza au final enfin j'aurais
préféré qu'ils gagnent des politiques
aussi quoi lasser des croisières il veut
pas se laisser décrocher pourquoi mais
je pense qu'il se barre pour passeport
de butembo radieuse le prendre mais il
va se lever pour voir quoi c'est
magnifique non mais je pense c'est une
très bonne chose
parce qu'il est jeune il est j'y gars
talentueux il va réussir à régler tous
ces problèmes mais je pense que ça va
lui faire gagner du temps d'avoir fait
sa force envoyé vraiment tout le monde
entier alors ça s'est mal passé
après je sais pas si les avoir empêchées
mentalement quand même temps - peut
toucher quand une nation c'est enfin
réellement un 2-0 second degré je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose
parce qu'il va reprendre son destin
entre les mains il va enfin il va
reprendre son si les valeurs auxquelles
je vais être champion du monde comme
j'ai envie de la sg pas envie de copier
akram micoud enfin ce soit je vais faire
comme j'ai envie en fait fin
lui l'a jamais gagnée les candidats
pourquoi je devrais l'écouté fin je suis
un peu ce truc un peu arrogant tu vois
mais qu'il a peut-être besoin de
retrouver enfin depuis avoir un montant
1 - genre de mentors ou quoi
je pense que c'est il va retrouver un
peu son et créer un peu son style quoi
ça marque
on va essayer c'est encore bien
honnêtement ton entraîneur si tu fais ça
normalement enfin je sais pas c'est
comme c'est une équipe de foot bon c'est
pas du sport individuel et collectif
toujours différent mais tu as ton équipe
à l'entraînement il arrive matin à 8
heures ils ont dormi tous une demi-heure
de ses côtés de ronaldinho en gros c'est
que le vestiaire et enfin l'ambition le
vestiaire l'a lâchée en fait c'est
pareil c'est oui bon bah en fait tes
conseils d'un regard je fais des
buvettes toute la nuit en rien à [ __ ]
ta deux présidents de clubs sont là si
on regarde on est en ligue 2 mois qui
suivent à faire avec ton club tu gardes
le coeur au gallon d'essence nationale
à la faute on s'est fait maniement
et romeyer et caïazzo quand ils
regardent enfin fous peuvent être très
très con quoi
non mais ça peut être bien
banis qui twitte indirectement qu'il
jouera probablement le match 6 et contre
n'est pas il a écrit quoi
après je vois pas magnus refusé de jouer
n'est possible car ou deuxième je vois
pas un monde où magnus margarot devenir
champion et vice champion du monde c'est
un gâchis je passe 50 millions d'euros
et moi je suis champion du monde
notamment d'argent coin
étape le titre je citerai je suis plus
riche que toi il faisait chaud fusent
audience shirts ou riches c'est le titre
être comme ça quoi
moi partout
[Rires]
il a écrit un mec qui ne devrait pas
parié qui jouera le guen contres et pau
car il est ambassadeur de paris
responsable
ça veut rien dire non charikar ou qui va
être deuxième
à voir le yatenga kiki et la zambie mais
est obligé de jouer il peut pas laisser
hikaru devenir champion du monde à sa
place pas possible
il peut
mais je ne comprendrais pas qu'il fasse
ça en fait mais après bon je comprenne
je comprends même pas c'est pas le
problème
c'est hyper surprenant
et si féru de la deuxième année ce sera
pas fuir ou de la deuxième est en fait
plus possible
dépôt c'est beaucoup et j'en avais marre
de me faire mousser la ja je me barre
c'est ben ali lui calme comme ça le truc
ouais mais c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il
le fait
nature à fléchir un peu
quelqu'un disait que ma nièce avait plus
à perdre qu'à y gagner à jouer n'est
programmé pour moi en fait s'ils jouent
pas contre mais pau il est peint il a
perdu on vient de perdre c'est si tu
refuses de jouer ses fins ben j'y peux
rien tu peux l'avoir battu 12 50 0 la
fois d'avant
des revient bas il revient et si tu
refuses de jouer c'est que tu as perdu
tu es moins fort en fait pour un parfum
c'est ça aussi le problème femme du
classement elo aux échecs il est encore
numéro un mondial en fait je devrais
avoir un
teint que tu vas tu as comme s'ils
refusent de jouer tous les grands thèmes
du père desbois
ladder djoko perd tous ses points mais
c'est normal en fait tu ne peux pas
alors les spots ce refus il peut pas et
celui qui fait il compte pas pour le
classement n'a pas de chance
mais j'aurais rogers ils font au
classement ben c'est comme ça
mais tata d'état des gens qui sont
spécialistes de one piece c'est comme si
qaïda mais refuse d'affronter le fit une
quatrième fois
mais la part refusée
rater l'us open aussi on fera deux sur
quatre et un acompte pas en fait il a
fait un grand chelem sur tf1 ça aurait
été beau canada y a une nouvelle fois en
finale de roland contre rogers elle a
battu l'an dernier je ne joue plus à 5,6
le plus fort regarde même pas sur le
terrain je vous jure que toi tu as gagné
en garde à vue je suis plus forcée pas
joué donc non non si tu joues pas tu as
perdu point barre
la pose de caruana échoue on peut aller
voir un peu lent et les chaises vides à
eau
autour de mai pour black swan correct
tour vite en est un c'est prend des eaux
n'a qu'à qui fait plaisir
heinz nikov
de nouveau la même structure 1 et j'ai
une lente que je jouais en fait je
plaisir oui
ils sont km boarding et
suit move alias chevaux à technique de
bischwihr qui
exige selon du sexe
c'est très bon quoi ah ok on lisait
caruana ding ça peut être une grosse
partie et accueillir son trafic
cargo entre ces cons là souffle alors
un espagnol
en finale
ces fameux fou des voeux bref je faisais
pas mauvaise et toujours dirigée contre
les cavaliers à 5 un peu vrai y en avait
quand même je te prends pas
peut-être kf5 trop vite g7 je connais
aussi bien se préparer si je
passerais bien un gars
comme ça
d'après de dingila encore un petit chat
de 6 nuls
un petit faire trois sur trois
est ce que tu aimerais jouer aussi bien
que naqaba oui bien sûr
qui n'aimerait pas à jouer aussi bien
que n'accapare karl scène
mais bon j'aimerais beaucoup de choses
pas que jouer aussi bien que maka
après si je vais choisir une aptitude ce
serait pas celle que je choisirais quoi
de jouer avec ma came in the sound un
truc de prendre à son compte en banque
maintenant il n'y a pas assez
avec des si on coupe du bois refn board
on a joué comme famille business qui a
beaucoup plus intéressant son jeu
beaucoup plus faim
mc a été vraiment plus riche que magnus
je pense je pense ouais en fait je
ressens rien mais enfin derrière truqués
sortie qu'ils estiment 50 millions de
dollars sont sa fortune 47 millions
d'euros généralement ce genre de fortune
ils sous-estiment un petit peu
généralement pas mal quoi on magnus
avoir pas mal de sponsors vatican on
sait pas que parce qu'on ne sent qu'il a
créée que disons il a
cherché tout ça
c'est chaud d'un à cinq ans après magnus
sûr qu'il a pas mal il ya match
peut-être mais je mettrais mes tricks à
vous devant
et oui ce serait beau tu fasses hikaru
playes magnus plaît mais en fait si cars
où je pense que ce serait la seule
personne en fait au monde à pouvoir
ouvrir un site est concurrencé jazz
comme et biches s
franchement s'il pourrait vraiment faire
un truc très vite à autre chose qu'à way
up in app purchase je pense pas vraiment
faire mais après tout ici bosse avec
chaises comme depuis longtemps je
connais pas un du tout sourire après de
leur nuire particulière non non mais je
sais même pas s'il a des pays est très
possible qu'il ait des
départ au départ ou agence est
absolument un spa parce qu'on bosse et
qu'on est là sur la chaîne de jazz comme
qu'on le sait on n'en sait absolument
rien mais c'est possible t'as pas ce
serait intelligent de la part d'autres
choses comme en fait de
rester tranquille
mais il pourrait en fait c'est un
individu qui peut faire plein de choses
dans les échecs parce que papa ce qui
crée une vague d'équitation une belle
vision j'ai remarqué que son congé des
points de vue sur des trucs intelligents
que sawai caroit dit la même chose mais
vraiment je traduirai tient cette
cadence ce serait mieux au genre de
format serait mieux et quand il qu'à
rouen des gens lui demandent où ils
discutent apprécié à merveille on
demander à icare où il pensait pense à
peu près la même chose et il a
globalement et même quand je suis j'ai
pas le même avis que lui ce qu'ils
disent est souvent intéressant sens est
intelligent sa décision il ya pensé à
toi sont il peut se tromper ou quoi mais
il fait pas au hasard n'ont maintenant
plus on sait pas si j'ai un bip on peut
ne pas être d'accord pas voir là mais en
fait tu peux pas dire que ce qu'il dit
c'est pas cohérent ou pas intelligent en
fait je pense ça marchera pas comme ça
mais tu veux pas dire c'est débile ou
tuant suis sûr que ça marchera pas où il
a tort plus avis différents mais c'est
toujours pertinent quoi vraiment
quelqu'un qui a une belle vision
demagny c'est tellement plus large que
celui d'akkas ouest sérieux j'ai pas
franchement
schéma 50 millions c'est pas mal quoi
sinon mais c'est pour lui le problème de
trucs pas toujours mais normalement il
essaye d'estimer au
plus bas pour pas faire part que des
plus riches que ce que tu es
venu je sais prendre leur parti
en avant un bel affrontement aujourd'hui
entre les chaises
pas selon internet la mac à cinq fois
plus que magnus voie puisque toi
mais non mais bon quoi moi je parle
qu'on s'est mis à discuter ça mais c'est
sorti ce matin aussi ouais non mais un
article je sais pas ou
[Musique]
parce que ces prêts parce que c'est pas
prêt pas dit car ou de dix cars ou moins
d'alireza dur à dire
non mais en fait je pense qu'il saperait
ce qu'il fait en temps normal il a
également affiché un peu plus
donc c'est peut-être bien justement
c'est vraiment mais faire semblant que
ça joue non mais c'est cette prépa
non ce fait annuler la petrov venu de la
petrov pas comme ça
trente mille sept sur dix ans a fait 15
millions voire arrêter avec les calculs
les frérots
arrêtez enfin vraiment qu'ils arrêtent
les chiffres ne sont pas bons
malheureusement non
non non c'est terrible
les chiffres ne sont pas bons
à rien euros les mille vues sur youtube
où elle est magnifique cette légende
c'est terrible
c'est terrible mais peu importe
bon époux qui ne réfléchit un petit peu
après ceux ci prend des
bons
élèves auront position ça joue en fait
mais je trouve ça correct pour les noirs
je passe les tours s'est vite si tu veux
cassis bessin et peut-être
même bêtise peut être cinq ou
huit évidemment
vam b6 damas cinq tours ces huit tours 8
celle écoulée quatre coups que tu
regardes n'en développe même à 602
d'autre le faire bessin et prendra ce
fait la b6 après
en fait les noirs faudra juste penser ou
fausse être confère soit le ramener soir
des gones à la suite un donc son aide si
ce soit via cuite g7 soit une lande et
b6 peut-être un jour tu qu'on tourne ta
seule pièce était pas trop ravi
globalement ça va et pas de faiblesse
c'est comment on va vivre déjà son
prénom harry
n'ont résisté paris appelle déjà longue
ouais
quelqu'un a rien ravi ouais rien n'est
pas très arrière à vie quoi j'étais pas
loin de haricots c'est beaucoup à harry
a ravi
j'avais quelqu'un qui met la justesse
qu'il a gagné il a gagné sept cent
soixante treize mille dollars entre fin
2019 et 2021 angoissé on est loin de 15
millions en disant
regardez tous les choix soient servis
nutrition à 775 milan 2 ans hors impôts
après c'est beaucoup moins aux états
unis qu'en france mais hors impôts quand
même important toujours donné hors frais
de fonctionnement et c'est donc en
france ce temps les vrais 80% avec tous
mais à
une telle qu'elle est atteint en plus
non ouais ouais et tu peux peut-être
faire un monde enfin je sais pas je
passe fiscaliste américains mais en
france dans les vrais entre 75 et 80%
entre les frais de fonctionnement et les
impôts aux états unis chez pas
mais on peut pas savoir combien lui
reste mais c'est bien loin de ça quand
tu vois ça faux
depuis 80 ans ont intervenu ben pas tout
à fait 80 peut-être juste aux 75 entre
les les frégates fonctionne entre l'epic
pas les frais tu payes des gens pour
travailler et après on prend donc à peu
près ça en gros
mais bon peu importe n'est pas là pour
parler des revenus des streamer est là
pour regarder les candidats quand même
mais après dépens des pays site à malte
par exemple ça doit être beaucoup moins
et en france 1,6 à malte dans les ceux
qui en payent le moins au monde et quand
tu es en france tu es dans le pays hôte
en payent le plus au monde donc ça
dépend beaucoup
du pays où tu habites et ça tu peux pas
le savoir en regardant trois vidéos
enfin veux pas savoir en fait c'est
impossible donc laissé hikaru compter
son argent
et compte est le vôtre
entrer la 58 50 millions me fait plaisir
enfin moi je suis content bah oui ça
s'est bien passé
donc
c'est bon mais pour un peu lent là pour
jouer quand même on pense à dire ça oui
clic bien on est très heureux de ça
c'est pour faire une partie est clair
hélas non les pompistes ya six ans les
chaises vides décevant en fait c'est
marrant parce qu'il a passé des heures à
jouer ses autres très bas et là c'est
encore préparés qu'ils cliquent tout
s'est tellement la bonne stratégie ce
qui est en train de faire non mais je
suis pas sûr ce après pas du tout la cie
femmes
mike leake juste
est ce qu'on va voir cette semaine
samedi soir normalement et ce soir si ça
finit tôt et ce qu'on fait la bay arena
ou pas je n'ai pas annoncé justice fans
ici ça finisse et on la fera peut-être
ici non non ça dépendra si ça belette
partout qu'on fini à 6 7 heures
bal et être partout mais malheureusement
non
on attaque défieront
malheureusement
ça ce soir si ça chine guito
jolie dans le chat
fou les cinq possibles pour les blancs
prochain
bah ça me serait pas venu spontanément
passé doit pas être un coup qui permet
en fait vu que t'as plus d'espacé avec
les blancs tu le vois pas 4 5 rangées
les noirs plutôt de 3,3 me
tapant des choix trop de pièces et noir
plus urgent est une pièce ou deux vont
être très très serein
car william
donc
mais ça ne ferait pas halal et blanc tu
envie je peux pas te fait roi chien tu
te caches de cette diagonale as tu de
ton style noir des 11,3 tout autour
c'est un d'amener de peut-être tu mets
ton rang loin en d1 je sais pas trop où
un truc comme ça je regarde cf4 avant
c'est pénible
bavière faut tu as tu fait des trous
comme quand tu le fais mais des fois tu
viennes du temps et tu repousses des
pièces
voilà
way to éviter les échanges de pièces par
an maintenant d'ailleurs ça se voit que
c'est ce qu'il veut faire bouger garde a
fait trois pas foule au début donc c'est
bon danser ce prix là
je pense qu'ils connaissent un mais je
suis pas sûr
fassbind connaître reading
sais rien moi la fille 25 minutes ding
il peut connaître un bien sûr et
vérifier ce qui fait
tellement responsables des trois non
j'ai refait tout aquatour web et 3 pour
safin un pion central x 2 août à les
changes et sur ses premiers vagissements
recueilli ces six revenir en b 4 enterré
et où mettre le fonds a st et coup je
sais pas quoi donc j'aime bien le coup
de ding c'est parce qu'il vous en soi
mais visuellement il me plaît
je suis plutôt pour ding en fait ouais
dingli gêne d'ailleurs c'est là votre
prononciation je croirais pourtant
alireza jusqu'à maintenant c'est sa
meilleure partie dans l'ouverture et
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas jouer on le
voit pas sur l'écran
bien joué il ya eu un petit un petit peu
qu'on est parti à jouer d'un v6 décevant
réflexion d'avis mais sur france 3 il
veut quoi d'un prend b2 j'imagine il
s'est pas enfermé 5
et surtour bien ta cavaliers 3 et urt
apithy
hockey
croit chant peut-être
la tour
à laquelle sept tours est fort venir
embêter adam enfin je le trouve pas très
fin
je souhaite le fond et fuite si jamais
non mais ça va ça va prendre pour la
position c'est sûr après ça joue une
partie d'échecs mais attend à voir
cycliques vite non il réfléchit il faut
cliquer
il a réussi jusqu'à maintenant le clic
et loisirs mme bourget ce simple coup
j'aurais eu le temps de jouer déjà six
oltra belette bah oui
treyvaud qui jouent contre
baky quoi pour s'entraîner la vie
je rentre adversaire très dangereux un
certain baky 83 à
très beau joueur de belette
abba ou sinon c'était juste après pas il
n'est pas décidé ce faisant tu cliques
et puis là il va nous faire une bière de
réflexion
on va voir
pourquoi maquis 83 à et pas bâti 83
parce que baky 83 étaient déjà pris ce
qu'on va être baky c'est un manga et
d'animé très connu un personnage de
manga et d'animé très connue donc il y
avait déjà probablement un gamin du var
j avais déjà privat qui 83 quoi donc bon
bafoue bikey si oui on va dire bye-bye
qui avec 6 83 on va qui cassera 1,3 à
qu'est ce que tu vas faire
84 d'un débat qui est déjà il est né en
83 et on s'est mis dans le var donc
double 80 troc double 83 83 à
crucial le ah bah oui le a est très
important
wei un débat sur skis les forces bas
qu'ils aillent est très fort et je l'aï
m qui se perd à sangoku mon canton
beaucoup n'ont sangoku très fort enfin
il a vu le prince tincquois donc fait
très attention
wesh parfois dernièrement choix qui se
battait contre un certain granola j'aime
bien le nom de code mais je suis quand
même
granola je ne sais pas très peur comme
méchant
ouais sangoku baky granola nom en bas
qui est au dessus de granola ouais
je suis pote izia saitama qui met tout
le monde d'accord m et saitama après ce
que je sais dans le
il en sueur phase 1 qui s'appelle
comment
en fait ya un méchant qui a tué son pote
à ça m'échappe
montbéliard où elle s'agace le chanteur
quoi c'est encore très très fort et très
fort ce sont 26 copies tout ce que tu
fais tu fais une attaque instantanément
il sait la faire ce que toi
et il a des attaques à lui de base juste
un idiot mais c'est une attaque et rohff
très bonne résistance c'est un peu un
con quand même et retraite il fait que
recopier cette attaque en premier et que
tu le touches tati
avec il a un truc à lui quand même de
base on ait eu copie
ça spoile lisez ainsi voulait pas être
spoilé normand
c'est terrible parler d'équipage un truc
ont disparu spoils folle ça va
tony montana meurt à la fin de scarface
ça c'est un spoil
oued façon genoa 6e fait des hausses à
chaque fois ray
le titanic coule c'est ce que je voulais
dire
je veux qu'on se voit des scènes
qu'arbres tu vas avoir du mal à ce
poignet
on connaît on connaît déjà
prochain ok bout qu'on attendait ça va
la clique assez vite comme moins vite
que le reste mais assez logique il
enlève le roi de cette diagonale de
clouage du cahier des quatre et ils se
cachent tranquillou
tour effet victoire à ses huit au fc
vite
tous ces coups là
c'était vraiment un truc de barjots dbz
composite ya besoin d 1,90
ah bah oui c'était quand même très au
dessus un ajustement préféré de
l'anglaisé doigt mais tout le monde qui
fait des bge elle
frise art très dangereux quand même
celle aussi
supportable selon elle son petit rire là
tu vois que tu es plus puissant que moi
mais tu n'es pas assez rapide pour me
venger je les détruire l'univers
[Rires]
je n'étais qu'à 1% de ma puissance
j'ai passé un an à 50%
choeur cvo avec quand ils arrivent tous
à un tracteur avec ce n'est pas là
et complètement dégoûté quand ils le
voient offrir à
faire ça
donc ça le fait chier
est vrai le l'autre l'a vu quand il
s'appelle le père de freezer je prends
pas de façon terme sur le mentor qui
demandent les pea trucks qui lui donne
maintenant que les tons et
pvp ou en fait ils défoncent avait pas
longtemps l usirf éléments les plus
importants sur youtube plusieurs fois
pour bien intentionnés assurerait est en
fait je me disais que un dbz avec
freezer doublé par vlad ça pour être
exceptionnel
j'ai toujours su que tu allais faire
cette attaque
metric la réentrée prévisible est
vraiment très nul balle au pied t'es
sympa aussi moi j'aimais bien et j'avais
du zodiaque ah oui
les chaînes de l'infini et a déchaîné
blair
phoenix des gaz dragons chevaliers du
cygne
son truc est tombé de la glace
intel comme sangohan n'a aucune chance
contre moi
non les têtes avec sourire très grave
lors un truc qui me voilà l'énergie
monte quand il s'énerve sans gagner tout
petit va nous remettre un coup du pied
de son armure comprends pas à quoi nani
n'en fallu faire une forme de néo poko
intel comme toi ne gagnera jamais
l'écran
par un coup force à f4
c'est pas quelqu'un force attaque le
cavalier qui va rebondir ailleurs mais
bon f4 qu'on dise à 5 ou tu regardes
façon pour enlever le le cahier 2,5
après
que je sais pas si c'est très fort
je sache quoi ouais
le truc c'est que j'ai plus trop de
batterie de les recharger un peu
ah oui c'est très bien je vais faire
sans brésil fab
les raisins meierhans belette ou en
partie je pense qu'il est meilleur en
boulettes à
veulettes il est vraiment très fort
enfin petit bard hargett
wave 4 voies blain
les résa qui calcule mais faut qu'ils
cliquent en fait faut pas trop calculer
faux clic clic clic
ils sont typiques de là
f 3 ar s avec ça ressemble à une bird
avec
f3000 en dehors d'elle kf3 week ou de la
bird cf4 mais
moi je pense ça ressemble un peu à une
italienne qui érige et 5 mai sans que
les noirs et poussé en d5
ouais bah c'est bien ça m'a un peu de
lumière
ça ressemble un peu aussi une grotte
messanges et 4è ça peut ressembler à des
positions noura bref
impossible et position de catalan mais
avec le fouet le feu de la passion de
ghettos de passion qui était
alors son ménisque ans dynamo si oui
mais utap a échangé le pion des
saveurs le plan de l'écossaise
s'entend aussi un grand miroir est
sans une attaquante
bad
au showbiz c'est exact opposition et le
icône au cul c'est génial
je viens on va être les gens vivent
seules ouvertures qui connaît les bons
les russes parfois quoi
ça j'en sais tu qu'il a joués alireza
ouais
j'ai des smartbox
on veut plus quoi
john fox ici
[Rires]
à jouer la nuit way
françois
cette finale de la berline haut de gamme
et qui rapporte
ok bon il a mille j'ai déjà une position
très similaires dans ma pratique gens
réellement
j'ai même la partie dans une base
et ça ressemble non monsieur classique
enfin si
j'avais gagné
leurs sites yahoo pour faire autant un
joueur à 2100
non j'avais fait quoi j'avais changé ça
et ça contre ça et ça je vous propose
est clair mais sur la belle diagonale
après j'avais un échange et 5 contres sa
c4 le ton pas chez l'option de sa eric
tu prends même jamais pour bien le
bloquer ayant fait penser que c'était
plus qu'il est fou de vouloir opposer
moment maintenant je te comprends cet
été avec une tour j'ai poussé le pion à
mercier d'attaquer cette option mais en
fait je connaissais pas ce plan donc
pensé s'approcher de la nulle
détrompe toi
et donc
elle a pris du fouquet bon j'ai une
copine va le prendre
autre chose serait étonnant et peut-être
x 5 vous quoi qu'on dise ah
bon cornaro joie série sierre
où elle réfléchit ne connaît pas ne
connaît pas d'être position bas je pense
ça fait longtemps qu'on ne connaît pas
mais juste oui pourquoi il réfléchit
pourquoi ils cliquent pas ça c'est une
belle question on sait pas en fait il
faut cliquer vim
bref avis va reprendre
en fait avec les noirs étaient pas loin
d'être gagnant
si tu fais x 5 je sais pas si à tour
boucher un trou de forage fuite
et tours 8 où qu'ils aillent vite voilà
tu gagneras un centre mais x 5 ya
peut-être des f3 intermédiaires et on
empêche que tu mettes le setup
exactement comme ça hyper bien sûr les
dames c'est déjà trop venir avec des
cahiers 5 ou donc c'est assez concret
mais ce qui est g7 ça peut vraiment pas
le temps de lecture calcul mal un truc
et l'ice bar et attaquer à tour pour ça
que vous dites-vous rex taux plein
ah ok mais écoutons
belle partie en tout cas
ouais bah écoute on attend un peu un
saut
raté sympa car les hyperboles est en
fait on aurait des coûts quoi
sa clique ray
mais il chaos qui peut battre rapporté
revenir aussi un mais faut que faut
qu'il faut que les surgelés
poursuivants gagnent des parties
serait bien qu'ils carreaux gagne
après bon sa patronne pour rapporte
apa spéciaux position rapporte
ok mais espère une victoire du hb louey
le hc le
scrs
et mon comptant la chanson papa oui
elle reste six salles a pas mal
d'ailleurs un fab j'ai un peu regardé
pendant la sieste j'ai regardé une vidéo
ça a l'air vraiment pas mal
un petit rs6 d'ailleurs dans une des
chansons de jul que je prendrais rs 3 4
5 ou 6 quoi fins et bah ouais mais
l'arrêt si ça vraiment l'air une belle
voiture est-ce que c'est des évolutions
avec le 3d plus anciens ou quoi ou c'est
vraiment un choix à 3 peut être mieux
selon paris c'est de plus en plus
puissant que le rsi ça tu veux pas assez
dommage
donc on va l a6 michael green a redonné
green ardo il vient sur verre d'eau
c'est sûr après mais je vais te montrer
dommage pour pour notre stage qu'on
aille toi t'as pas un air est vrai pas
du tout
regard l'urss a vraiment l'air champ
mais
magnifique
mais là sur la mêlée rouge et patronat
seguinar de la grille nardo
poids à vide ça fait 2 tonnes plus de
deux tonnes
sans la puissance pas mal
puissance 441 kilowatts
ces bons rsr s6
s6 et rs6 v8 toi est ce qu'il ya des
gens qui ont investi dans le chap
600 chevaux
ça tracts bien quoi
je tourne à vide et imagine avec nez
pourquoi
je suis fier ou qui a joué avec a joué
quatre demies driver va pas non
j'entre au regard des récits
par contre les prix ah oui et c'est des
occasions en plus en plus des hakkas
fort stream est un petit peu ah ouais
si ce salaire
giuly les hits rs 3 4 5 ou 6 mois
c'est bon puisqu'il va aider
ces futurs et si c'est ce qu'ils veulent
dire par bird je veux dire qu'ils sont à
la dame noire en b6 dans cette ouverture
un arrêt donc du coup ça ressemble
vraiment beaucoup vous désolé d'avoir
ironisé dans la barre d'état souvent la
dame ait 6 du coup tombée g6
ça ressemble
dépendre de comment les nord joue quand
même
donc sur f4 le coup le plus classique
sur la merde cédé 5
je fais ce système mais si c'est
bon imagine
f458 from
ça ressemble au plus quoi
ça peut ressembler à beaucoup
d'ouverture pas du coup mais qui de 10
salariés qui ne fit quatre ses six pieds
trois dames b6
ouais bah voilà en plus tu empêches le
rock était très bien quoi ça ressemble
un peu
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait ça pourrait
ressembler à une française s'est enfin
de 4,6 d4 d5 regarde
5 c 5 ce sera fou 17 est ici kiev 3 vous
avez trouvé cinq là peut-être dans la
partie aussi
imagine veut dire bon bah tu enlèves les
pions ouais tu recules lui en fait tu
arrives à faire un
jeté de dés et tu pousses les pions sans
les prendre donc d4 bah franchement tu
es presque quoi après tu veux cavale tu
fais rock prochain est froid
ben voilà c'est pas long
c'est pas loin
nico coup de main de nico et à dos d'âne
mais c'est celle unique aux cédants on
joue ensemble ah bon c'est dans tft
car oui oui ok
je faisais plus lourde en moyenne chaque
os que j'aimerais bien et nikos et là
c'est le petit le petit truc vert là que
tu mettais sur la carte pour rester qui
d'autre avec chaque haut que l'autre
assassin très intéressant
et quoi eko eko itxako c'est ça
une petite à cali c'était pas mal
d'échos plus ce
dernier donne quoi ça ça ils vont plutôt
ans enseigne mais ils ont fait la fête
existe même plus c'est vrai qu'ils ont
tout changé quand les bains il change de
personnage en france il ya plus chaque
os pourquoi je crois pas que les chats
coup là il ya des dragons c'était plutôt
intéressant
c'est terrible on prie ne laisse pas le
temps de jouer un jeu et que quand on y
joue quoi
les gens qui jouent beaucoup mais qui
joue va pas aux échecs on joue beaucoup
au jour des tours quoi
vous allez chaque côté tour
les jours des deux jeunes filles
devaient
pas y jouer à ça c'est un fait ah bah
oui assassin par les pairs à la base
annoncée voilà face à saint lô qu'est le
la fif et la dh quoi
aimerait bien aussi je viens son petit
rire
très très bien ce personnage que
j'ai fait ça change fin de semaine c'est
insupportable bah oui si tu joue pas
tous les jours c'est dur
mais est-ce que tu auras le droit de
jouer a lancé une version c'est que
c'est juste plus et 18 ans fait que ça
change c'est bien que tout existe en
visite ont choisi ton truc
intelligent ça les a souhaité qu' chose
que ça change trop vrai
dire on va faire le résumé on va
peut-être attendre le coup de d'alireza
avant de résumer ça devrait arriver
parce que c'est un coût qui va qui peut
changer pas mal de choses bon ça c'est
bon 6e tour bien bon et auront ces trois
donc ça change pas mal
f406
qui a 4 et
7 arrive il va avoir moins de temps que
n'est pas bien c'est
une tradition
on dit belette tout en fait ils étaient
tous là est retombé dans ses mauvaises
habitudes non mais peut-être enfin juste
sa prépa et puis en début de prêt pas ya
plus de clics
il s il est un rsi cic gares et des
piétons
ça sent le coup de mer non je sais pas
un nom mais je veux un coût normal mais
là vraiment c'est un dépôt qui cliquent
trop bas fidei cliquez en bas j'ai dû y
croyais pas trop mais bon du
g4 ou 17 c'est si ça va être fait des
coups normaux mais il perd pas de temps
à se questionner trop sur toi c'est 8 3
c'est vite d'un v6 damas cinq mois
shawannah
faisait son truc bim
c'est pas un joueur de bird un
nom
avec ceux-là bird
ont passé un bon début d'aprem on semble
fab
s'écoule
sur un best of des on-dit stream de
candidats complètement mais il sera
peut-être moins riche en deuxième
semaine parce que saint cloud de vigon
voit plus du tout
lieu où il fait quoi dès que ça perd un
peu côté français tu le vois plus de
façon mais c'est pareil pour les title
de bakirkoy j'ai perdu une partie des
bons
dexia gagne pas il se marque
mais tu fais vraiment c'est sûr que fin
là il doit être là l'an vers 16 heures
pour récupérer le le le résumait il est
pas là mais c'est assez incroyable en
fait on a déjà remarqué dans les
tournois on a fini par le démasquer et
en fait c'est terrible et dès que ça
roule gagne ici ça organe il revient au
labrador ils regardent que quand ça
gagne on s'envoie bout du compte ces
dépositions des chaque lan mais c'est un
supporter du psg en fait ça footix quoi
gtx c'est un échec x ouais c'était
impressionnant
dès que ça gagnes pas tu le vois plus
celle 6è et s'il revient ça gagne bah en
fait si sagan il revient mais à
contretemps quoi donc ils report après
paris repart après ouais c'est un
spectateur typique de ligue 1 est
l'un des premiers chez 6 de l'histoire
lui en fait avec saint-etienne soir
était simpliste aura été de regarder les
matchs henri iv match des rouge
du dj je suis comme ça aussi c'est un
cousin
par trois avec le psg ah ben on peut un
peu quand même
tata droit d'acheter tous les joueurs du
monde tapas fair play financier est à
rien si on n'a même plus le droit de
troller ça va être compliqué un
périmètre la clique dans les stades le
stage
je pense pas ici mais non j'allais dire
ils en ont pas besoin parce que c'est la
clim tous les ans en ligue des champions
désolé times oh celle là elle fait mal
saleh le faisait très très mal elle
était belle et je quitte
[Rires]
la salle avait été bâlois ont souvent un
peu qui fait ça va alors allez rigoler
un peu
[Musique]
j'avais vu venir en benoît rêve elle
était belle
ça vaut l'avoir vu venir elle était
belle
le cam des supports très beau joueur
bobo vieri tu vois gerry qui est un très
bon en scène thierry tellement dommage
avec un tel nom d'être supporter du psg
avec elle et c'est un énorme et à
déférer très puissant le bison français
sont dans 10 zones aides et des fois ils
étaient là ont la surface il te dégager
tout le monde il va finir monaco nous
oblige à monaco au sort afin de se garer
joue à l'inter non ouais ben l attaquant
à christiane very well
tu te dis c'est quand même c'est comme
un coup franc en pleine pleine lulu tu
le vois venir mais elle est belle quand
même c'est ça en fait
il a joué à l'ail ou vais il a joué
aussi à l'ail ou peut-être après homme
et je joue dans plusieurs façons et tu
te rappelles cet attaquant brésilien je
pense était aussi
adriano non pas d'alter way est bon
aussi vu un homme en fait il avait un
gros potentiel c'est un énorme genre ps
il ya des stades de ouf il est hyper
fort mais je crois qu'il est une couille
dans cette fois peut-être son père est
mort ou un truc comme ça et il est parti
en dépression et il n'a pas du tout fait
la caf qu'il aurait pu faire
viry débute avec dell tiroirs la jupe
quelle belle équipe
ces quatre puissances mais après moi
j'adorais puis aussi parce que mon jeu
préféré donc ouais
d'organes est une terre à cette année là
c'était c'était quelque chose que
j'avais recoba très beau joueur et
l'inde et l'inter qui a terminé deuxième
side du calcio et d'accords passés
derrière le milan ac vrai qu avec giroud
mais j'ai une belle équipe le milan ac
ou pas brise la tania giroud en fin dé
très bien quoi mike maignan au goal
tateo arrière gauche c'est un peu une
équipe d'anciens non un peu de tout rôle
de 200 heures de
garde à vue c'est un peu la période
basse
trois ans c'est plus
ça reviendra un de ces quatre
mais cela thani là il a quel âge 40 est
tout le temps là bas ma fille j'ai plus
trop quand même à la fin il un peu
blessé l'épreuve au genou
milan 1er 2e et l'international est
meilleur je suis content s'ils
reviennent ce cas un beau club ils ont
eu dix ans après les compos jeudi que ce
qu'ils font
ça redevient
une équipe sympa trapel et pas plus avec
shevchenko a mais la dalle et 2006 ou
familiaux avec side of gattuso pirlo
desjardins
a été jugé excellent une à toi mais tu
avais vrai talent inzaghi de vente
affichent une cote avec kkr meneur de
jeu enfin c'était monstrueux même les
remplaçants seront grozny au mieux
qu'ils pouvaient venir un peu mettre des
coups de main la défense sten esna
maldini stamm à un moment très lady day
all cafu façon déjà convaincante à
gattuso pirlo milieu du terrain aux ag 4
mais magnifique c'est tellement un coup
de merde programme
on voit sans voix quoi
pim
gattuso c'était mon milieu de terrain
préféré tellement fort ce joueur
d'apporter une telle confiance au milieu
de terrain leur servant un gars qui
tacle un peu trop on attaque la basse
avec eux mais oui mais c'est bien le
genre comme ça ah bah oui ça va c'est à
dribbler mon pote jusqu'à sa gamme et
estévenens instant un fou mais tu as
besoin de mecs comme ça un mec comme ça
c'était une sorte de robbie keane du
milan enfin de vraies oui c'est en fait
s'est il bien tu expliquer à tout le
monde que s'il ya quelqu'un qui a un
problème il est là mais on avait lu une
interview fantastique avec avec la ddt
pour la finale de la coupe du monde
contre la france
il y avait ces six ou huit oncle qui
était venue de calabre pour voir le
match
je veux pas les décevoir ouais et puis
bon tu comprends que l'équipe en face
aux fins faut peut-être mieux pas gagné
l'aller huit ans que le calabrais kit
attendra la sortie
il peut y avoir d'un gris tu vois
les cas ça ressemble à une grotte way
du coup j'ai quattro est mais je ne sais
pas quoi dire en fait c'est chez betclic
bah il veut prolonger singo fief quattro
aux puits et sinko et puis pousse ses
pions mais juste sur à chis bah je sais
pas c'est logique je sais ça fait torje
ou non achat battu
3 6 1
j'ai à dire c'est à dire suicidaire
dame prend b2
mais on va voir vous avez vous fait le
truc c'est à dire suicidaire mais après
n'est pas aussi réagit mal il peut
perdre enfin il va par sa petite nul
voila il tente sa chance g4 je sais pas
ça m'a l'air bon
même en blitz quand tu joues tu sais que
c'est pas bon mais tu le fais quand même
tu dirais je clique
qui j'aurai une dinguerie qui passe ou
quoi habiller quattro mais tu sais que
tu fais un coup de merde
à moins que ce soit brillant mais ce
dont je pensais déjà meilleur que j'ai
pris mes fils
bon va pas une bonne tête non plus
l'aide doit faire le résumé
donc femme partie importante ici pour le
classement final du tournoi lire les
avirons déjà le feu follet finalement
contre yann nepomniachi leaders avec un
point et demi d'avancé il faudrait qu
ali reza frapper un grand coup pour
remettre tout le monde dans la course et
louvre par quatre femmes oui et donc
mais pau qui joue sa petrov aux quatre
cinq élèves trois cas graves 6 quelles
épreuves cinq des six kf3 qui prend le
cadre du grand classique et elle est
restée bien qu'une petite idée ici c'est
quattro donc l'idée est simple c'est
d'empêcher des cinq est touché aux pions
des plus tard voilà de l'année au centre
éventuellement n'est pas surprise
spécialement il fait qu'à lycées 6 des
trois rentre chez toi qui as valet f6
des quatre en avance parfois les enfants
des cinq pour pas laisser les blancs de
faire mais lui il a plutôt fait flouer 7
les blessés alireza prendre de l'espace
cavally 5 et d4 refuse des changes des
pièces puisque avantages des espaces
pour pas trop voilà on pas trop liquide
et petit rock cas ici trois
développements fuji 4 est toujours dans
cette optique de pêche rue des piats
stif f3 plutôt que de le fou rentrer
chez lui en dix-sept foule de ses six
pour casser le centre c'est assez
logique lui a permis à veic f3
d'affaiblir la diagonale à on va le voir
revenir dessus tout à fait petit rock
comprend des 5 comprend des cinq dames
b6 toucha diagonale roi h1 se décale
tour à ses huit jusque là eu que des
coûts logique de part et d'autre et on
est dans une position compliquée
dynamiquement ali reza qui est peut-être
un f4 intéressant ça se calculer mais
après une longue réflexion de 25 minutes
il envoie g4
un coup
somme toute étrange pour une partie
longue petit daim gris on verra ce que
ça donne mais a priori c'est quand même
assez assez affaiblissant bon il veut
faire g5 l'once atteint scanner peut
jouer à 6 pour calmer les ardeurs de
cette expansion allait droit et on verra
la suite
merci ferment pour soi résumé
l'italie fait exprès
john bon sens
un professionnel comme d'habitude fab
mais ça qu'ils auraient pu jouer deux
lettres que j'ai quatre en fait le tempo
mot n'est pas fait à justice par contre
il s'assied mais on va voir un petit peu
sa tête
il a fait des sourcils
c'est à dire qu'est ce que c'est que ça
mcg 4
est ce que je pense être j'aime un jour
et non je ne vais pas essayer
waro pas le temps pas l'envi et puis je
suis trop vieux aussi maintenant déjà 35
malheureusement même si ça ne se voit
pas non mais je peux comprendre qu'à la
caméra tu penses que j'ai 22 23 ans
voilà c'est aussi normal mais il ne faut
pas se méprendre pas se fier aux
apparences non
dépôt il doit lui sinequa mais après tu
te dis c'est un franc-tireur un feu
follet non mais tu as tu un peu dégoûté
quoi te prendre un bain il a fait vu la
situation paraît normal en fait ça te
saoule qualité clickz à
22 tours bien c'est que tu sortes ta
reprend ses droits pour l'instant on a
des mecs autour bien ses taux d'intérêt
bien faire pour faire [ __ ] trois ans
un truc après
bâle sis à s'expliquer mais il a raison
n'est pas de passer je trouve qui gère
vraiment bien non là ils seront un truc
un peu bizarre évidemment c'est un peu
relou dans les situations de tournois et
tu cliques en fait il a emmené le clic
on s'en est ce que dépôts ne
travaillerai pas avec baky on sent qu'il
ya du clic au hasard
mais qui tombe bien ouais mais bon sang
c'est l'école backis la nasa
s'est déjà m des gens deviennent grands
maîtres à 40 ans alors dans le temps ça
arriver parce que tu as des mecs qui
jouent et largement au dessus du niveau
grand maître mais qui pouvait pas sortir
de leur pays pour une raison x ou y ou
qui pouvaient pas jouer les tournois je
pense surtout à des joueurs soviétique
mais des joueurs comme ça qu'ils
reprennent à mon âge à 35 ans et qui
deviennent grands maîtres mon avis c'est
rarissime déjà il faut beaucoup de temps
et d'argent malheureusement du vagin
pouvoir le faire ils ressortent souvent
l'exemple de bingöl je sais pas trop je
sais pas trop son histoire en fait mais
peut-être qu'il était grand maître tard
je sais pas non généralement hyper doué
ben en général non les gros joueurs
bensaïd gold en fait
devenu j'aurais même à 60 ans n'y a pas
longtemps en gagnant le tournoi seniors
ah oui mais ok si c'est en gagnant le
championnat du monde deux vétérans quoi
saliver norton donne dans les rames en
face et on parle vraiment là nous du
titre de grand maître en l'obtenant
faisant les perf à puce de 2006 et c'est
youri chabane of the traveling to money
was that is even
ouais mec et il a commencé les tournants
à 27 ans et mais oui enfin perso c'est
gratuit soit je suis pas conre il a eu
son truc en soixante six ans j'avais pas
trop l'histoire mais shabana que j'ai
déjà vu des
parties dans la basse qui se trouve que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec jean-luc
chavanon et je passe le bonjour s'il
écoute yakima pas mal entraîné aussi et
qui est un grand maître français très
sympathique et à révision oui c'est mon
cousin russe tatiana chabanon cheveux
noirs
je connaissais pas le mec m'ont fait
chaud c'est pas le bon je vais juste
donne
d'ailleurs je connais chabal of way très
connus grands maîtres américains iggy
fort en plus maintenant qu'il a un peu
vieilli quoi mais je dis rien n'a été
vraiment dangereux
chibane of
chamanov chabat nov
jean lui qui a été un très beau très
fort en maths français
qui est toujours grand fait d'ailleurs
elle le sera tout le temps à vic
dû construire extrême en open ya
quelques années très sympa ray est
toujours très marrant
jean luc est devenu jeu g est assez âge
non je crois pas qu'ils soient devenus
grands maîtres je pense est en 2002-2003
par là j'ai pas trop quand même
c'est le seul moyen que j'ai jouées dans
ma vie si j'étais gagnant 10 par an
c'est pas possible
mais à mais tout ça pour dire que c'est
rarissime et il ya des cas on avait
sorti aussi un grand maître qui était de
20 joueurs qui grand maître à 60 61 ou
peut-être cinq ans je n'ai plus l'âge
m'a pris je m'étais renseigné oui en
fait il était très très fort en union
soviétique mais il est tout le temps et
demi pouvait pas sortir faire les
tournois tu peux jouer tu vas pas de
personnes et est aussi le cas de joueurs
comme vinetot lynch je crois on a fait
une vidéo avec mathieu on va en faire
deux autres mais je crois qu'il était
que maître international mais clairement
s'il avait pu jouer ils seraient devenus
grands maîtres nejmeddine à tout ça dans
votre nom mais ces joueurs qui étaient
bloqués en union soviétique emmène
donc les 10 rue d'après eux qui
faisaient les grands maîtres en 2001
c'est à peu près ça à l'âge de 30 ans
ouais mais 30 ans a surtout vrai c'est
pas si vieux pour être que pour devenir
un grand m non mais surtout qu'en fait
c'est une autre période oui pour la
période en plus
il ya vingt ans c'est autre chose y
avait peu testé beaucoup plus difficile
de jouer à 2006 il ya un temps
qu'aujourd'hui à l'époque où il a fait
c'était beaucoup plus dur que maintenant
dépôt en forme en finale pourrait être
intéressant contre carlsen part
normalement il va se faire exploser mais
bon mais bon il faut jouer en fait mais
dépose sur le même truc gratuit yens une
partie contre carcassonne qui mène au
score ce sera un autre match hyper la
première c'est fini et
alors qu'arsène c'est pas pareil même si
perdre une il va pas lâcher la faire
quoi donc nos impôts il a cette phrase
dite est là et c'est comme ça mais dans
le premier match plein de matches qu'ils
ont fait l'an dernier là il a bien tenu
pendant quatre cinq rondes a tenu le bon
je vais rien à dire ça jouait de parts
et d'autres du même cinq nuls et l'a52
ok ok et après celle qui perd qui durera
dix paires longtemps mais il a ses
chances à un moment où il peut enfin ça
joue pas à grand chose dur dur dur il
finit par la perdre un énorme combat de
partie la plus longue je viens du monde
135 couple tarder un truc comme ça
ouais bon ok il a ça l'a tué mentalement
et dans le jeu était pas à des années
lumières avant ça après il ya plus photo
s'était terminée tout le monde descend
mais bondissent guidarini est devenu
grand maître à 35 ans je trouvais
tellement fort je vais vraiment bien
mais guida il a une il a lâché le jeu
professionnel assez vite il donnait plus
que des courses et il s'est marié ne pas
pas y donner des cours dans son coin et
il voit quelques open ici ou là
et puis il avait pas mal de normes si je
n'avais pas avoir 2005 et bien un jour
il va faire quoi mais voilà mais il
avait le nouveau beau joueur aurait fait
quand j'ai commencé à se retirer comme
ça tu peux nous juste ne jamais l'être
que tu joues plus tu perds ton et l'eau
etc mais
[Musique]
c'est pas une histoire de niveau là pour
le coup c'est vraiment moi si je m'étais
jamais arrêté j'aurais pu le devenir à
30,35 même 40 mètres x qui me suis
vraiment arrêter complètement joué
pendant dix ans quoi hein et puis là le
truc c'est que hors jeu vont être
longues années le poids des points d'eau
j'ai pas le temps et
200 premiers lots à prendre
mais j'ai bien géré même en ayant 20 par
tournoi il faut jouer dix tournois que
ça se passe tous bien mais rien que oui
de temps c'est important ces dix jours
je voit pas réussir à jouer à 2005 en
plus plus plus du tout c'est vraiment
dur enfin sais c'est dur juin 2005
devant moi j'arrive
ouais mais c'est dur non c'est
probablement pas si simple parce que
l'on n'est pas si nombreux mais c'est
pas si leur non plus je sais pas trop
dur pour moi
beaucoup trop dur
non après ce serait plus fin
pour des gens qui ont mon talent donc un
talent assez réduit il faut vraiment il
passait beaucoup de temps pour apprendre
les ouvertures vraiment loin par coeur
et tout est un c'est vraiment facile
voilà que qui comme moi
tu calcules mieux qu un fab suite sous
estimes tu calcules beaucoup mieux
points
bon kick au hasard et peut-être
légèrement été at-on niveau peut-être
même un peu supérieure donc là je veux
dire qu'en partie mais tu joue beaucoup
mieux que toi tu calcules plus vite tu
comprends mieux
le clic
après ces différents mais bon
malheureusement
comme l'essence du jeu le clic ouais
mais quand tu as que le clic
[Musique]
nan tu t'es battu calcul nettement plus
vite comment
lambie c'est qu'il a l'air de vous je
pense femme un poil plus fort que moi
mais à ok ce serait pas si on fait des
matches après on n'aime pas envie de
jouer ensemble parce qu'on est potes on
aime on a tous les deux ce même défaut
certaines qualités on n'aime pas jouer
contre des amis soit fabu mois donc en
plus quand on doit jouer ensemble c'est
catastrophique on n'a vraiment pas envie
mais je pense en blitz ce serait serré
c'est un peu plus fort ça j'en suis
certain mais je pense sur un match oui
non plus grand joie que je vous sors de
chasse comme
jeu c'est sûr mais oui c'est
vrai je pense à la même différence entre
krikor et toi qu entre toi et moi
je pense qu'ils corps un peu plus fort
que toi ce que je pense avant le match
ok le match un peu confirmé mais serré
et je fais en soi un peu plus fort que
moi je pensais le même peu de chances
différence quand même mais oui c'est pas
c'est pas 3 030 quoi
mais ouais
ça serait honnêtement un couac de te
soutenir pour des matchs officiels non
mais les gars je suis nul en fait ça
aucun intérêt de suivre mes parties en
match officiel
enfin c'est stupide en fait
chacun sa place en fait il ya des gens
leur place c'est de jouer parce qu'ils
jouent bien et même fable c'est encore
sa place parce qu'il est vraiment fort
et moi je suis un clown quoi donc ma
place c'est d'être un clown je sais pas
comment dire
c'est un peu comme ça enfin il y aura
peut-être une chance de nous revoir voir
jouer en tournoi je vais pas plus paul
fabé déjà au courant mais tu peux passe
pas ils n'ont plus d'eau juste rien non
mais tu sais oui enfin oui peut-être que
ça ça se peut qu'on nous voit jouer avec
fab ensemble un tournoi l'année
prochaine mais l'alpe d'huez mon père
ali vous oubliez à tout jamais si vous
suivez moi j'y crois style venue à davos
il dit je mène à tout ibra piège en plus
on s'est renseigné on a regardé 13 km 9
de monter une pente moyenne à vie pour
cent et cetera bon
ben on nous a dit non mais oui même un
meilleur de sa forme quand il faisait
150 bornes le week-end il avait monté
pas facilement
et donc sévrier avec un petit braquet
bah si vous pensez que c'est possible
un vélo électrique non mais c'est vrai
que l'on peut il a en mobylette aussi
quoi mais il faut qu'on fasse le vrai
truc
savons que des 10 et pas si dur bon
après
je sais pas comment tu es sportif ça moi
j'ai comme un petit poids à traîner fort
que
tu as travaillé des jambes avoir une
mise en forme avant je peux pas y aller
demain c'est clair que non non il nous
faudra un an d'entraînement vrai - fait
que j'achète un vélo d'appartement et
que je fasse comprendre un peu de buzz
moi je voulais faire chez moi c'est bien
fait pour perdre du poids le vélo
mais par contre la décence je n'avais
pas envie on souffre on n'en peut plus
heureusement un vin chaud enfin je pense
qu'on rouvre une voiture pourra
descendre
à l'abattage ces choses c'est bien
les laudes à part qu'elle skie 16 quand
on habite à canet mais c'est des fous
furieux sur la route j'ai peur en vélo
j'aime bien faire du vélo en fait
j'adore mais j'en fais pas ici parce que
les gens roulent comme des fous et j'ai
peur en fait des voitures
font vraiment peur
mais ici dans le sud c'est s'aider
acharnée en voiture 1 c'est vraiment des
malades j'ai vraiment peur de me faire
renverser
mais bon je verse 1 tessa de monter le
col du grand bois des trucs comme ça
après un peu du lot il y aura pas de
limite de temps on va pas se le faire
on s'est
séparés ou alors au pire ont descendu à
pied je suis sûr qu'on le monde bah oui
si on monte ou ques km cr en fait
de new order ac dans le faudrait que ça
monte bien sûr est
300 personnes par jour essaye de le
monter et il n'y arrive pas là c'est
quoi les stades sur les 300 parce qu'il
faut
y en a 250 qui rentrent chez eux ou non
en fait
ce qu'il a pu en prendre connaissance
oui oui bon on peut tenir à reconnaître
venez faire pour toi qui dit pire le
ventoux qua
non périmés il le vend tous ses
pirouettes sur ses pieds on perd il
roulait vraiment bien fait il était
vraiment très très bon un vélo il m'a
fait peur enfin c'est rouler super bien
s'il est dans le chat il va nous dire
oui mais j'ai roulé très bien mais
il envoyait du très très lourd donc si
m'a dit que c'était dur ça me fait peur
c'est que leur moyenne ça nous va très
bien on fait on le fait en trois heures
des records
en train de l'écrire attend non ont été
dérobés des âneries
serait bon d'avoir un peu comme priseur
oui je suis vraiment sûr qu'ils ne
monteront pas la plus à même à 100 % de
leurs capacités ils n'ont aucune chance
à deux kilomètres à remontrances 7h sais
pas je pense 5 km a franchement sur les
pentes à 10 à 10 % c'est pas facile non
mais des fois ce sera un peu moins un
peu plus vieux que moi je sais pas si on
tient sur le vélo en fait
on ne s'est pas
hissé 6 km à la vitesse minimale et
c'est pour ça on peut peut-être pas
monté juste parce qu'on ne peut pas
avoir la vitesse requise non mais s'il
va signer aux rares donc c'est la
vitesse qu'on a appuyé
ouais mais quand ça monte un rude c'est
pas si facile un nom mais du coup le
vélo de chacun puisque à pied droit
enfin à 6 on peut y arriver
on va viser la montée en 3 heures
et quand ça mon truc tu vas plus vite à
pied mais ça j'en suis sûr qu'en ca
montreuil s'est passée la pierre
on se trouve en danseuse relance un peu
fâché moi j'ai déjà eu un passage à vélo
à 20 mai à 22 % je te jure que j'ai posé
le vélo même puisque julien au pire on
ira là-bas on n'arrive pas enfin un
camping
prévu un passage quelque part c'est à
moscou à 20 22% je ne suis pas passé
j'ai pas réussi en fait
et peut-être je sais pas moi 100 m 150
mètres j'ai pas réussi
20 2% tu poses direct ah bah ouais dit
fin j'ai c'est impossible mais j'ai vu
un gars ultra costaud à côté il est
passé
ben ouais mais
tu passe pas qu'en fait
donc là et quand c'est à 11 ou 12%
cantal km à 11 % je suis pas sûr qu on
le passe je suis réellement pas être
peintes pas convaincu qu'on passe le
kilomètre à 11% en fait
je fasse on essaiera d'ailleurs mais bon
ça peut être un très beau défi
loin d'être sûr de la réussir mais bon
est ce qu'on peut aller voir un peu
peut-être ce qui se passe chez caruana
indigne
la ce a su après h 6
mai 11 km 1 et l'a fait roi je suis
direct ça être cavalli avec cinq tours
g8
ok bon ce position intéressante je sais
pas trop quoi dire
compliqué
compliquée
défaite pour ça pour ça on va chez toqué
compliqué et non la paire de fou niveau
structure ce pas mal mais dont phil un
pion pour un quand même donc voilà ils
vont essayer ce qu'ils vont essayer d'en
et du estime qu un jour c'est une
rupture quand même un dans la position
et sinko pour faire jouer le foot c'est
6 peut-être un jour
attaqué le pion b3 ça j'aime bien les
perspectives des noirs mais on verra si
c'est optimiste de donner un pion ou si
justement
la difficulté à prendre il faut compter
l'attitude tu monte à plus de 3000
mètres non l'alpe d'huez c'est 1800 1900
mètres d'altitude
sur le peu de noms mais je suis loin de
vous dire c'est bon on va le faire on va
réussir et puis chambas on va essayer
mais revenir sur le délire d'hier
dinghy clic tempo en tout cas il a l'air
très fort ding de
cavale est aussi si pour caruana dame
prend aussi souvent et puis deux fois à
5 en fait c'est ça l'idée
mais il ya oui mais bon que tu repères
b3 rémois yann d'adjamé il a témoigné
c'est clairement moins bien tu as quatre
attaques et
les gens sont plus actifs une structure
moins de faiblesses
et cavaliers mal placé
oreilles coupede
grégory coupet ed
din joueur exceptionnel mais enfin je
suis tellement déçu je me répète un mais
du fait qu'il soit arrivé à sittard
parce que malgré tout pour moi c'est il
devrait y avoir un mano à mano entre néo
peau et ding en cette fin de tournoi les
deux sont les plus forts et un tel écart
n'est pas méritée sur le niveau de jeu
après c'est les aléas du sport ensemble
avec arrivée plutôt à une épaule a su
conclure quand il pouvait à ce que dit
n'y a pas fait donc clairement le
réalisme c'est important quel que soit
le jeu se lâche le sport
il ne peut pas remonter parce qu'ils
gagnent aujourd'hui est que néo pop et
repas et que nepeut gagne pas pardon
ça peut mais en fait vu comment joue
alireza vu comment il réfléchit et vu
ses habitudes
lassiné peut gagner cette partie je
pense que c'est fini pour tout le monde
parce que même s'ils gagnent dinger
encore un point et demi des 40 ans de la
fin
alain stevez 3 sur 3 à knauf et claudine
déjà un ex-aequo mais tu feras pas 3 sur
3 si déjà de survie est déjà dedans ça
ferait une fin à six sur six noms
un peu plus tôt de m
non mais normalement c'est quasi fini le
tournoi en fin et pau devrait finir
premier c'est ce serait fan d'un bric
soit pas le cas mais il ya encore monde
un petit monde bah je sais pas s'il ya
un truc chasse by numbers qui a calculé
il donne 86% on sait pas dire 100% non
plus ses mots 86
ou qu'ils perdent ouais et aujourd'hui
simple
belle tentative pour permet aux
bourguignons
restent pour l'instant fait il a pas
l'air d'être tétanisé par l'enjeu n'est
pour les cliques viticulteurs écologique
et bien et un son que firent où il
s'empale un petit peu
on va avoir une façon fable il n'y a
plus qu'à attendre bah oui
fillon le premier fan d'anti calculé 84
au greffe 4g impression que
o'keeffe 4g dire l'équipe ranger 4 bon
ça c'est vrai mais h3 dessus
fille quatre maires fou c'est au pied à
faire braquer ses 4 1 mais bon j'ai
envie de prendre h3
caisse assez compliqué à
tous les caprices trompée elle est en
fait il lui arrive le même cas de figure
que je suis tombé à damas d'un madame
dessins de deux pions tallage 3 qui
rôdent
à fiat sa puce ses pattes après une
décennie quatre ans adam riess est il a
raison fixed au 1025 minute pour jets 4
il n'a pas prévu de cours après six
essais en fait c'est comme tous les
jours il a raison enfin tu peux pas
passer 25 minutes sur g15 qui qu'un coup
ci responsable et après le truc le plus
logique h6 retend que 25 minutes
ce qui fait alireza c'est inexplicable
en fait débuté comme s'ils savaient plus
jouer aux échecs alors après il a un
tellement bon fond de jeu et qui réussit
à jouer encore à 26 26 50
mais
sinon ça fait très amateur sa gestion du
temps c'est toujours pareil je sauverai
mais il ya un réel problème quoi c'est
on a déjà parlé on en reparlera mais pas
si là je n'en étais pas rendu compte
mais c'est vrai que c'est une fin c'est
comme tous les jours c'est hallucinant
c'est en fait
il amoureux ou quoi vachement s'il est
amoureux il aurait pas passé la nuit sur
l'île chess affaires du belette quoi
tu cliques aussi mais différemment
parce que là on va te j'aime pas enfin
fait pour g4 à une idée très précise de
ce que tu fais quoi c'est trop
compromettantes fait des trous partout
et témoigne à développer enfin tu as
déjà des vrais problèmes de fond quoi
peut-être une nouvelle partie
pédagogique concours bah ouais mais ça
peut être une partie très intéressante
en fait analysé nouvelle fois parce que
c'est des coups on nous demande souvent
qu'est ce qu'on fait sur g4 ou quoi
parce que ça a l'air pas si mal hein
mais c'est dur de réagir et peut-être
que les peaux et grâce à fuir aux gens a
peut-être avoir une nouvelle partie 6e m
contre amateurs mais à
meknes peau qui va écrire au tableau ces
intrus elle
ne pas jouer g4
mais ça peut être une belle partie
pédagogique en fait c'était parti hyper
intéressante pour les amateurs
réellement on est ce que ça montre
comment réfute les coûts qui
n'appartiennent pas quoi
mais c'est vrai on a souvent parlé de
l'importance peut-être supposé de signer
jana 1 pour l'epo pendant les tournois
qu'il a un petit peu cadré mais mais
c'est vrai que ça peut
jouer devenir ça peut jouer way
autre chose qui le cadre dans sa vie il
la paie un écueil un équilibre ah non là
souvent
on dit aussi que sa femme était très
importante dans sa réussite elle
s'occupait d'absolument tout pour lui en
dehors des échecs
donc ouais c'est pas une nouvelle fois
au troll un petit peu on rigole un peu
mais c'est pas
c'est pas si anecdotique en fait
j'avais moins bien les noirs en
égalisant je pense que les noirs sont
déjà mieux ici après un coup de tels
coups comme g4 et où il ya eu la maman
de kasparov aussi important
l'entourage est souvent important pour
carlson c'est son papa way avec x 2000
entoure et façon
mais ouais c'est pour ça ça peut ça peut
être un facteur décisif
mais vrai du couffin dalli s'est mis un
peu tout seul dans le pétrin
pas évident de trouver une suite non mes
trucs genre c'est quoi il fallait y
penser avant de fermer quatre
d une expression et derrière chaque
grand homme se cache une femme ont
vu qu'on me suis dit que peut-être comme
ça ou un truc comme ça mais
instable sexisme c'est pas du sexy de
lire sa fin j'ai pas l'impression enfin
c'est hyperimportant quoi d'être d'avoir
une relation équilibrée
6 enfin
moi j'aime pas ça comme ça
non mais tu as raison tu comme tu peux
plus rien dire c'est pas grave et dire
que ce que tu veux
les trois radios dans chatroom
vraiment très très grave
tu dis bien de la compagne de népotisme
alain
gras vrai que ça lui a fait du bien je
jouais je vois pas mais bon après
c'est raciste hussein les gros sofa
bossi
s'est
fait passer une réalité avoir une
relation équilibrée pour une fois réussi
c'est important pour tout le monde pour
une joueuse de haut niveau on dirait
là je sais pas
c'est comme ça
je comprendrais jamais mais bon en porte
à faux à coup
ça commence à faire une longue longue
réflexion sur ce coup
une bonne trentaine de minutes ou quoi
quoi
c'est homophobes parce que si ça soit il
préfère avoir un homme à la maison enfin
c'est une phrase générique si c'est un
homme c'est un homme et j'ai en fait
c'est
trop génial qui disent que c'est
homophobes en fait on réformer l'accord
enfin je sais pas quoi vous dire enfin
c'est pas possible je ne sais pas
comment dire et si précis femme préfère
être avec un homme se serait la même
chose soit géré on comprend bien ce que
ça veut dire la phrase
on peut importe les dix clubs c'est du
troll mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit
de chez tout le monde en fait on voit
des trucs trolls et on voit des trucs
relou qua
non pas du tout on peut importe
non peu importe son retour et sur la
partie femmes oui mon mieux mais en fait
c'est qu'on sait pas quoi dire sur la
partie à fuji trop il a déjà affiché à
faire le g4 est sur le coup de plus
évident il refait une demi-heure donc
donc de la partie c'est dur de dire
quelque chose que ce que j'ai quatre
services à un coût un peu tilt
enfin tilt ils vont trop ambitieux par
rapport à ce que la position peut offrir
et que peut-être là il l'a fait ils se
rencontrent en fait merde pourquoi j'ai
fait ça quoi
donc trop impulsif
et maintenant
rattraper les pots cassés ou je sais pas
quoi
il reste des places pour lisbonne ouais
il reste quelques places on en parlait
ce matin après elles sont plus bloquées
avec l'hôtel ce que ce qu'on dise en
accueillant la vidéo ce matin puisque je
faisais dans un autre live donc
sur la durée devrait de faire jusqu'à la
fin des candidats maxi apprécié un peu
plus compliqué
ou peut-être ça se débloquera mais je
veux dire crois pas garantir à très long
terme
ce qui expliquait moyenne il n'a pas
expliqué à fuir ou
de quoi
pourquoi y réfléchit au temps après des
coups logique
ah oui mon la personne n'a demandé non
j'ai quoi 3,6
donc
c'est comme
je sais je sais pas le chat est
complètement fou je peux le mettre en
moto2 ni un ouais je vais mettre dans
les montagnes mais c'est une très bonne
idée je le mette en et montagne
comme ça on aura plus de bêtises
vote beaucoup mieux je souffle jeu très
étendu d'un coup on voir ma petite au
ray tu souffles bah oui mais c'est
bizarre après ceux réussis ce d'autant
réfléchir vraiment un
bah oui mais en fait le truc smith a
fait deux semaines que j'ai à vous qu'on
dit les mêmes commentaires donc à part
relevé une fois de plus mais c'est c'est
comme d'hab y'a rien qui va j'espère que
ces passagers parce que c'est je pense
ce chirurgien il a tellement de talent
mais bon comme je le disais des fois tu
ta des trucs bizarres en fait dans les
carrières des sportifs de haut niveau
les jeunes qui arrivent très fort et
tout d'un coup ne sais pas pourquoi au
tennis est plutôt mitch par exemple un e
mail je serai absolument incroyable
quand il arrive sur les circuits avec ce
revers un peu nonchalant et puis et puis
en fait non alors que enfin moi je
pensais qu'il va être minimum top 10
mondial
où tu as un joueur de la 3e' arrivé très
vite très fort c'est jeanne x6 nerfs
alors il bondit mais se construit quoi
ruiner des fois tu en as en fait il va
ou dimitrov
ok il a été bon mais je veux dire par là
tu l'attendais duby fed
tu as
un mec comme cariou ce gros talent
machin puis nos échecs can skip
james key ça aurait pu être c'est un
champion du monde en puissance puis
finalement by hacavie au final quoi way
oui mais après l'arrêté arrêtez les gars
de dix ans plus tard il a l'air bien
joué en fait mais ça peut arriver
parfois des talents bruts qui arrive tu
dis lui il est absolument incroyable et
puis au final m'amène talent en quelque
sorte pas même si j'adore et là il y
aurait pu faire une carrière il a fait
en deux temps frais mais on est très
très fort
oubliettes et quinze ans plus tard
retrait fort oui mais tu aurais pu
penser qu'ils soient champions du monde
pendant 10-15 ans d'affilée un mickaël
talent avec son style du début
mega le match retour contre bobigny
enfin oui ma voiture je petrossian fin
c'est dur tous les votes pendant 15 ans
n'est pas fichu et puis genre non mais
qu'est ce que tu aurais pas pensé qu'il
serait champion du monde pendant dix ans
ah oui si voilà mais il a fait une fois
mégère par là des fois tu as un truc
bizarre at en a qui arrivent et qui
arrêtent un qui arrive pas à temps afin
tellement de choses qui peuvent se
passer en fait
ce que tu penses pas fuir une heure sur
le cool
non mais en fait non mais oui mais
est-ce que tu es là tu te fais pas de
bons coups mais peut-être qu'on n'a pas
en fait
est un peu plus quoi
l'ex
complexe à réfléchir en tout cas
ce nombre les faire un tour chez ding a
les seins ce que je te propose
ça va lui aussi sa masse est la variante
qui semblait bien pour ding à ben bonne
nouvelle ça peut faire punto chain pour
pour ding celle d'm6 fois fuite fois à 5
un autre peut-être il veut non mais fou
d66 adam franche et bill
tom était obligé de faire face à tous
ces formules adaptées juste moins bien
avec les blancs mais clairement ouais
mais c'est tant mieux enfin j'ai on
prend oui mais moi j'ai enfin
j'avais misé sur djinngo site à son
début donc à miser a toujours su que
j'avais pas parlé du tout mes jeux
c'était juste mon favori pour le temps
d'un coup j'ai vraiment l'impression que
c'est le plus fort du tournoi en fait
avec aînés pour de loin
mais une époque il va peut-être prendre
encore un cadeau quoi
ik au bénin non plus mais résonne pas
forcément trop suffire qui est trop tu
vas te faire entrer les tours d2 quoi
bon après ce qui est un tour de plus
fort encore être un peu précis et que
les noirs c'est pas trop dur je sais
mais bon
trop vague et
donc ça ok mais tu dois aller taguer tu
dois être précis mais en fait c'est la
précision pas trop duré
à rajin avoir du monde qui joue pour
rien
faire nous très vite celui magnifique
ils font pas six heures de jeu après si
ça finit tôt on aura une baie arena ce
soir ah oui donc on a intérêt en fait à
ce que ce soit torché à 18h30 a eu très
vite quoi ap ap ap ap
wengen gallega bay arena c'est beau il
ya des bons joueurs ah oui à la deux
semaines c'était un beau tournoi
ça à chaque fois des beaux tournois
h quattro
ça a l'air tellement con c'est déjà
moins 1
50-1 il en train de donner le tournoi
années pose sur un plateau
la vidéo s'appellera les candidats
donnés sur un plateau d'argent bas
surtout s'il fait donne deux poteaux
sont deux parties c'est une arme ouais
ça je pense qu'aucun joueur qui a pris 0
2 dans on est face à des retards mais
bon encore te dire que c'est mieux les
fassions plus d'un que les phases match
et machin femme continue à te dire ça
mais en fait là c'est ok j'ai 4 h 4
c'est pas sérieux en fait
c'est pas d'essai ok c'est même en blitz
on joue pas aussi mal en fait au jeu
d'échecs
c'est dégueulasse comme ça mais je ne la
donne pas trop légers sont ceux qui
osent 5 ha non mais tu donnes c'est
dégueulasse et j'ai pas les mots en fête
aïd entrave the world comme dirait
hikaru
non mais là c'est enfin j'ai pas j'ai
envie de vomir quand je vois ça non mais
ça m'énerve qu'on fait le tournoi de fin
faut retourner au match fabien que ça à
faire parce que
ça c'est vraiment ok mais juste donne le
point ne vient pas fin j'en sais rien
moi
j'ai rien contre férus du genre en soi
c'est plus le formate toujours les mêmes
choses hein c'est mais là c'est
d'après tu sais pas
c'est pas bien joué c'est comme hier
mais il est il que tous aient rien
contre eux lim en fait et ce qui à
chaque fois que ce sera un championnat
oui ça croit vraiment le meilleur joueur
ou pas et que tu vois que en fait c'est
assez fin à celui qui joue le mec au bon
moment ouais après une nuit blanche il
clique tempo dépôt alors après bravo
année peut ne pas avoir perdu dirait
letourneau quoi mais c'est vraiment tu
cliques les jours le bonjour est fait à
deux trois gars qui peuvent gagner par à
celui là c'était 24 gars en fait qui
aurait pu gagner c'est naka dingli
rennes caruana aînés peau et de ses
quatre ans fait suivant dans quel ordre
ça et tu cliques qui quoi comment
vas tu joues les candidats dix fois tu
auras une fois un des quatre vainqueurs
je pense
sur les conditions sont toujours en
chine ne se serait peut-être plutôt
digne parce qu'il aurait pas eu à sortir
etc ce qui aurait galéré pour venir
enfin
c'est pas normal en fait un faux pas te
dire mon sa couronne vraiment le
meilleur voire nous de trouver non pas
du tout en fait
mais bravo né peut enfin c'est ça
minimise pas du tout à perdre de dépôt
qui est vraiment très réaliste et c'est
ici une victoire à l'anglais soit mais
il gère très bien de tourner en rond
je vais très bien géré le dernier
c'est ce qu'il dit at on si tu perds pas
t'es pas mal quoi bon bah ça qui c'est
le seul a dû tourner à partir de
là il est justement non mais c'est pas
par rapport à firme bcia c'est par
rapport au fait que en fait si tu tombes
contre bon moment ça change beaucoup de
choses
et du coup pourquoi pas favorisé le
format match qui est déjà plus
intéressant pour le public et du coup
on soit c'est sportivement c'est pas
moins bien c'est pareil c'est pas un
chercheur joueurs qui votent moins
certes match tu tues tard fois
mais bravo à une épaule a c'est
ça il me fait penser à l'angleterre de
wilkinson
d'europe se baser petit jeu le ballon
sur un chemin dans ces trois points ça
regarde
mais pas il a mérité je vous paye c'est
vrai il a un certain bol là où caruana
par exemple avant eu la mal chance
surtout dinger mais bon après digne
c'est lui qui s'est mis dans la merde
tout seul en arrivant au dernier moment
mais peu importe c'est pas ça le débat
le débat c'est dire que si ce format là
ne réduit pas le côté chances du coup
c'est dommage de ne pas avoir un format
plus intéressant pour le public mais bon
peu importe on s'en fout
le format match je changerais rien c'est
applaudir ben voila tu verrais une
finale au lieu de voir des gars qui bat
des plots quoi pour gagner c'est quand
même plus intéressant mais non mais
c'était pas l'intervention de voilà deux
joueurs battus dans le tournoi qui vont
pas forcément défendre leurs chances
qu'ils ont défendues dans la première
moitié du tournoi
après le bas ce que je disais l'intérêt
du tournoi des candidats secteurs clé
mais qui croit il ya des partis à la vie
à la mort il ya très peu de nulle part
un taux anormal il ya encore trois
victoires en tire trois victoires en
match sera beaucoup plus de nul ou au
pire à les départager seront ça va
ça sera plus visible pour le public
c'est de trucs les deux se ce qu'ils
vont faire pour les candidats féminin
oui nous attarder match non mais les
deux se défendre
ni voilà je sais pas si on a un mur à
mon mieux mais les matchs pour moi je
suis pas contre en fait
historique non c'était plutôt les matchs
d'ailleurs si on suit la tradition mais
c'était des mots que c'est la tradition
portant la tradition là ça casse la
tradition ça me gêne un petit peu
mais je sais pas quand on commençait les
candidats en fait est ce que c'est en
1950 un par l'un
à l'époque très ancienne juste ligue a
débarqué le champion faisait son que
jean dujardin
128 rond n'a par contre abbaoui
62 c'était très long c'est très bien
or neuf le premier ok ça me tente 50
c'est ça ouais
t'as du tournoi tu dis mashiro des
tournois
et formant
ont varié
puisque et tours 8 il se place juste sur
la colonne ouverte estime vers la case
et fit pour le fou éventuellement mais
globalement justice pas ce fait les
blondes pas de menace et c'est tour
elles vont sans qu'un jour ou l'autre
elle servira en fait le problème c'est
qu'une ans a fait h 4 e faire j'ai cinq
ans dans la logique des choses mais sur
g5 écaillage 5
du google h5 c'est chiant sa noce kg 3
fourchettes et tu rentres mais h4 je
veux mettre mes amis qu un temps pour
vous lâche 4 j'ai bien réfléchi 36
minutes pour h4 donc il a réfléchi 23
pour gk 36 pour h4 et après tour f18 qui
est le coup le plus logique il reprend
qu'en fait non mais il est pas là en fin
de vie
[Musique]
sera pas du tout bon jeu
01 25 pouces est parti
jeu 7 5
ok bombe à la rame en effet un truc
compliqué sur caillage cinq bons leur
dis pas d'accord évidemment mais qu
humainement ça marche bien mais alors
venez tout a tellement l'air
non mais là tu es serein pas même moi je
veux dire piégeage 5 et 6 4 par exemple
on va dire oui c'est un coup comme ça
j'ai trouvé cheikh roger 2 qui est
prouvée fond saint ouen france 5
tu as un truc comme ça est ce que là il
ya moyen de s'embrouiller
j'avais laissé deux on va dire
à tous mes biens enfin elle même juste
âgée
âgées
à n'importe quel coût gagne en fait
c'est juste gagnant c'est qu'un maillage
des fonds très très mal
non mais attendez privat avoir faim
non mais je sais pas ce qu'il a loupé
pour aller se sent pas des comme ça
parce qu'en fait je comprends pas 5cette
cliquer rapidos par l'épaule
et je sais pas où ils veulent
embrouiller quoi
oui mais là j'ai agi kg si ce qu'on
regarde
il ya des trous partout quoi parce ça
c'est pas possible enfin tu peux pas je
veux ça de gaieté de coeur
quelle aubaine pour les peaux qui se
disait je voulais venir faire 4-4 partie
4 nuls t'imagines tu feras un cadeau là
ça donne encore un bonus défaite dans le
match à la votera t j en fais ton truc
tu as toujours des mecs qui donne les
cadeaux
du rapporte
lui rapporte ding et fuir ou trois
cadeaux avec les coins f1 trac avec les
lancers quand même pittoresque un
mail à petrov c'est quoi ta [ __ ] t il
trois parties à aulnoye avec la petrov
browning celle anglaise mais ben oui ça
fait 2 mais va quand même mais 56 tu
fais deux victoires deux nuls au noir
avec la petrov
pathé calmeront
sept sapeurs bas non mais tu veux tu vas
toi ton ferme et enfin elle ad'ailleurs
h5 c'est logique et de faire un jeu
prend d'abord salaires enfin je sais pas
je prends d'avoir peut-être sans le fou
- lafarge prend donc sa ressemble de
façon il va faire rage prends je pense à
les raisins
et calèches cinq façons
c'est exceptionnel
mais bon vraiment tous les sports le
truc qui manque après j'étais inquiet
pour maxime après les grands prix et
puis ça s'est bien passé maxime a eu un
peu de bol et ce à la salle a
complètement relancé après mais ali reza
pour les prochains tournois
heureusement que ça joue un rapide à
zagreb ça peut-être tête le remettre en
confiance mais sinon c'est quand même un
sacré coup derrière à kara fin
à bas le niveau de jeu est pas du tout
là
c'est pas un manque de réussite ou chez
pas quoi l'assemblée s'est passé à côté
du tournis s'élèvent dans les rangs 5 et
7 avril gagne mais alors on les grandes
largeurs thunder
bay ok
je rame le nord mais sembables under
qu'il enchaîne les coups mauvais
nombreux
4 sur 14 et pire on regarde les parties
a le truc je suis un surnom qui lui
permet il part numéro 2 du tournoi
en fait c'est pas comme si même même
avec cinq copains comme il l'a fait l'an
dernier lui par vraiment petit poucet du
truc donc si avec 5 août fait 4 sur 14
tu dis ouais bah c'était dur pour avis
les chercher des points machin c'est pas
si mal je pense que d'hommes qui l'a
fait plus je me souviens plus mais
est con que je fais partie des favoris
avant le tournoi
c'est un échec comme la secousse à
icare ou à lille car oui car on peut
vous montrer sa tête mais
vu ce truc est vraiment terrible
voilà c'est la finul déjà mais
on est reparti je suis maître sa
position politique
c'est à peu près ce qu'on a montré il ya
des compensations pour les dents
en plus ce qui est terrible c'est que
demain
hikaru il va envoyer la berlinoise il
veut enfin ça sert à rien de tenter le
gain s'il a deux points de retard à
trois rondes de la fin ah oui c'est vrai
ça fasse une demande d'amm de 4,6 à face
une rapide et que ça entérine vraiment
le tournant à deux rondes de la fin
quasi saturé on nous dit avec 5 au
cinquième victoire et c'est pas mal cinq
et demi alireza précis fait trois nuls
aux trois dernières il va y arriver mais
oui c'est pas du tout la même chose ah
oui non si le palais que c'est aussi
quelque part les trois qualifications
va quand tu regardes le grand suisse
s'est qualifié ali reza alors attention
c'est hyper dur de gagner un immense
bravo à lui ou quoi mais il manquait
plus de la moitié du top 20 mondial
y'avait pas icare où il y avait pas sow
ne guérit pas guéri pas les bonnes
toutes les mains dans les veines il a
joué ça c'est son problème si je me lama
mais
y avait pas mal mais c'est sûr plus on
sait sur qui avait pas mammeri fabi et
maxime
des familles maxime leeuwen et firent où
déjà les quatre gros favoris à côté
avait pas gris tchouk
manqué beaucoup de monde donc finalement
cédé tour a qualifié apathique n'y avait
pas rapporte et peu de chinois y avait
pas dit n'y avait pas rapporte
il manquait beaucoup de monde
bon après c'était fort tournoi de
l'avoir emporté mais c'était pas contre
le top niveau oui alors par là que par
rapport aux autres années dans sera
qualificatif était beaucoup plus faible
que d'habitude et bon ça à cause des
normes qu'ovide et tout mais ça aussi un
peu changé
pacolli alireza soit pas qualifié mais
aussi la phase de préparation tu étais
pas qualifié en battant des tops ou
parce qu'il avait joué deux top dans le
tournoi l'iresa tops mondiaux maxime ils
avaient fait nul au blanc et caruana
perdu au noir
donc c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
que les autres qui sont qualifiés en
battant des via les grands prix
s'avèrent plus dur enfin plus c'est pas
plus c'est différent mais vu dans ce sud
ans ça ressemble le plus à ce qu'on a là
en fait non epa duda et packard et qui
n'est pas magnus mais bon ça après oui
malheureusement
il aurait joué ça aurait changé le
gp avait personne en plus et là tout le
monde je verrai ton grand prix voyez
juste padding
vaisseau il y avait ma mais il y avait
un rapport
unique à roue et on voit là en fait de
20 à rognan il avait tout le monde c'est
hyper fort les grands prix
après vous assez qualifié de complexe
effet pas grand chose il ya une
quinzaine louis saha de la coupe du
monde c'est un peu le même
oui mais il n'emploie il sait pas grand
chose en toi mais ils implosent pas en
fait tu gères par là c'est différent
il a autant de poids mais il rate on
tourne aussi duda en fait faut pas dire
que c'est un bon tournoi
et mes duda
5 points de moins que à l'iiasa aussi
donc il était moins attendu on dirait
bon
y'a personne ce qui était tout d'abord
militant et non non
et duda c'est un peu comme rapporte
c'est des mecs qui peuvent être des
trouble-fête ils rapportent ils sont
plus connus pour être des joueurs un peu
sur courant alternatif ne trouve pas
qu'il eut énormément de réussite dans le
temps d'un prêt défaut d'arbre de noël
et des fouines super mauvaises décisions
contre la couronne et pau mais hier la
partie faire apporter des biens quoi
finit par la perte mais franchement
tu perds après une partie comme ça c'est
pas même truc que père danger preuve si
ces machins là où ça aujourd'hui quoi
d'ailleurs à porte basse ian et on lui
dit bravo super party et encaissé 4 et
tous
ces voix-là
de contenu content aussi en fait je
reviens
en fait ouais pour les résidus trop de
ratés de la partie allait contre l'epo
qui pas bonne il ya pavillon de thiaroye
nile absente à une bonne partie hier
c'était la cata la pire de toutes est
pris aussi un peu de réussite le
rapporte au début août ont éclos et
c'est perdre celle là ça parce qu'il
n'était pas contre radjabov il n'était
pas loin de perdre la première il était
perdant contreras partie leur at on fait
il n'est pas lié par les joueurs qui ont
le moins de réussite du tournoi en plus
on en rate et on a raté voilà non mais
il faudra tirer les conclusions et et
revenir plus fort hier d'une façon de ce
tournoi on dit que finissent 8e ou
deuxième bon fois ci il faudra dix
huitième troisième ça changera rien donc
à la rigueur
oui si bien à tour 9
juin dernier ça change rien c'est lui
bref on prend les points elo tapant il
est jeté à la poubelle normalement mais
le moins de réussite sedin qui rapporte
suis assez d'accord de ce qu'on a vu
boofzheim ayant of d avant le tournoi et
c'est l'afrique ram nick s'est déjà
morte pour les candidats mais c'est beau
en fait on toujours second souffle à
nyamina vraiment dit ça le nostradamus
s'appliquera mixer c'est déjà fini pire
choix possible
il dit des fois des conneries nostra
réagissent mais des fois yves
quand il a raison il n'a pas raison à
moitié
ce niveau ce sera quoi les points loba
aux invités en tournant après ali reza
de problèmes communs mais si tu perds 70
points et l'autre à concevoir des
problèmes il va pas les perdants ce
tournoi mais d'en perdre 20 ici 20 la
bave un truc pas papa tu passes mureaux
25 mondial c'est pareil quoi
jade avait raison presque tous à part
n'est paumé en fait je ressens qu'il n'a
pas de bol sur des pots en plus alors
déjà il aime vous savez faire biais
cognitif en vue qui n'a pas de bol ce
que la dire que dingli rennes grand
favori quand tu vois le niveau de jeu tu
vois que c'est un peu un 50 50 avec
n'est pas bon tu peux pas prévoir que le
gari 24 heures avant et qu'ils se
donnent chaque mais au niveau de jeu il
est vraiment la digue et
ouais en fait
rage et 2 bon j'ai consistant il veut
utiliser colonna
[Musique]
mais en fait des efforts menés pour
trouver un truc fort lesquels j'ai six
f4
qui es tu vas patron d'un cavalier et tu
sacrifies je prends vous prend dans le
premier de
sa paire fable
c'est fini non d'approuver la vente
directe
et sur food est là
ok mais ça il va pas trouver hop j'ai
pas tout à tuchan même surtout des deux
tu te fait en france et trois en fait je
suis pas un truquage qui a des trucs
bizarres balata d'options pour la fin
oui j'aime pas la qualité droite
est en mesure de trouver quand même mais
ok ce que c'est pas si simple non dame
prend b2
mais bon tu vois tu touches tout quoi
non mais c'est pas simple il peut avoir
envie de faire juger six
f4 qui a réalisé 4
t quand même très bien réussi
non c'est très positif parce que ça
c'est le truc pour
pour faire très très mal et réfuté le
jeu blanc
bon après les parties at il dit comme ça
ça on va dire que normalement c'est une
partita 95 80 % de chances de pernes et
à peut-être 10% de chances de gagner je
sais pas comment dire non mais signer
pour jouer un coup de merde quoi
25 ou s'il trouve kg 6 ha ouais
mais c'est pas si facile là bas nous moi
ça va je clique sur une turbine c'est
pas trop dur mais
c'est ok j'ai six à dix juste pour f 4
kgs ces quatre fois g5
ghb on va prendre ce qui est des quatre
en l'air
leur chance à la partie mexicaine et 6
pas dire non c'est pas qui a et g 6 qui
fait un dur c'est ça qui peut être dur
ce fut un dur moi je vie dure en fait ça
en prenant en compte la situation du
tournoi le fait que nul tu suffisent en
prenant tout ça en compte la suivante
est-ce que des pièces en l'air des
cloches partout mais bon
[Musique]
oui la tour c 4
ouais mais bon
tout autre avion pour la pièce cet acte
où partout et au pire tu fais dame prend
à deux tours a damé 2
je te prends la surprend et j'allais
prendre de quatre à quatre contre quatre
qui est peut-être
mais
gk ici jusqu'à la savoie que c'est fort
ça vient un peu plusieurs sites ont ces
quatre années après cammas est bonne il
faut des vite aussi attrayant il ya deux
coups en fait maxime d2
c'était quoi
accueille quatre noms oui il faut des 8
a l'air fort aussi d'après leurs dires
mais jamais ça tu sais pas facile pour
moi je vous filez vite c'est dur là tout
à coup tout en fait s'attaquer au québec
4 way et surtour bent adam ii d'amd 5
mai j'ai en fait t'as sorti
si tu te situes harcèle comme un petit
animal non mais surtout que lui peut se
dire mon pire enfin si c'est que nul qui
lui fait peur ils vont pire nul en le
tournant ça mais je comprends il peut
vraiment l'avoir n'est possible c'est
pas
impossible je pense dur maxime on a la
chance d'avoir une fusée dans le tchat
moi j'aurais dit pas si simple moi
j'aurais raté par exemple
d'un autre côté je joue pas les
candidats donc
ça qu'après telle optique ace et 4 août
est quand même bien et à perdre prendre
ds de fou
face à lui de voir je pense qu'ils sont
ils à 1h20 qu'enfin 15 lits
il peut il peut réfléchir et c'est un
petit mot sur la position
on va voir
ce que ça que fichman et pendant cette
position
c'est dur peut-être nul quand même
battre peut-être pas ce que c'est vous
qui agissent ou quoi au pire un moment
donné ça crie sur l'oral répète
bon ok j'ai six enfin ceux qui nous
regardent pas si après truc tu vois kiev
4 parce que pas de laisser venir il est
enfermé caillage 5 dont tu vois le
sacrifier dame prend des doutes vois que
tu attaques tous battus à rennes un peu
tous les coups de défense s'il y en a un
qui marche mais tu dis bon quelques
attributs logicom mai
ça peut être un coup par coup mais non
parce qu'en fait tu veux pas jouer au
coup par coup bah tu peux pas jouer au
coup par coup ça et tu te diras maintien
coupe je verrais bien après quatre ans
au pouvoir avant 7 heures à l'avancé
le numéro un français il est parti comme
ça alors maxime qui peut ce qui se
rapproche avec ses candidats de la
frontière plus face française et sedan
perdent encore
non ce sera
si l'on reverra maxime numéro un
français en tout cas on le suivra en
direct bien évidemment c'est quoi le
plateau de think de file ya mvl c'est le
plus important le rien sauf à ce qu'il
annonce et où je crois qu'il peut y
avoir du jeu crois que ailleurs du
carlton qui a été invité au ici les
autres j'en ai moi aussi mvl de toute
façon je regarde tu y as carcassonne
tant mieux ça permettra lui montrer qui
est le patron et
après le reste c'est des faire valoir
dans le cas où bilan
aucune idée
s'il est là pour poser les bases ouais
je n'aurais six cas où elle a pu
retourner sa retraite tranquille
jusqu'au prochain cycle parce que
peut-être lui a donné envie un peu ou
qui est un peu jouer des tournois ici ou
là lorsque je disais je vois pas prendre
l'avion faire le tour du monde il n'ya
pas car le cinéma ça c'est encore plus
facile de gagner c'est tant mieux
je crois qu'il était invité après
incarne celle ci joue pas à tant mieux
le saumon à cette période de l'année
avec causes du gulf stream ne va pas
s'aventurer aussi non à revoir le
message de maxime qui nous a répondu je
crois
et je suis choqué sont des vues
et des choix qu'après il nous apparaît
écrit
soit une vel mamessier rucka juan un
effort oriane rapporte dominguez à y
aura encore du sceau dominguez beaux
tournois
aux buy imola il ya des chocs de partout
à fable iii beau plateau
je fais une petite pause à laymont fab
femme qui part en pause qui attend le
cavalier g6 donné poney peau qui peut
tuer les candidats ce soir à trois
rondes de la fin il peut assommer le
tour à savoir de phuket chars quoi pouga
nachi
nuls pour duda mais ça fait un moment
dans là nul doute à radjabov
nacarat porte ça devrait faire nul au
cias s'est tranquillement et ding qui va
tenter de frapper et garder un soupçon
de suspense
c'était tellement mieux le ton à l'année
dernière je trouve ya zéro suspense
on peut du même acabit que le match de
championnat du monde ce toutes celles et
quand même les événements principaux des
échecs c'est ça qu'on espère pour
attirer le chaland et la hype bon format
aussi il faut dire magnifique
sur douze matches
vail ben c'est pas qu'une question de mv
elle en fait si tu avais les joueurs qui
un tournoi resserré en tête
live serait complètement là
après c'est bien pour faire les siestes
c'est comme moi devant les émissions de
corne et aux gens voient des belles
siesta
la prime une erreur données probantes et
pau qui peut choquer dans le sens où
s'il trouve un sextet sa dernière
séquence de quoi trouver pour gagner le
tournoi réellement aussi si caruana ding
ça fait nul à côté naka va pas gagner
s'il a deux points d'avancé à trois
heures de la fin
est ce que furent on va renvoyer des
belettes ce soir je pense en fait non
mais réellement un fable qui rigole mais
ça va renvoyer du bellay teint
c'est magnifique le bla toute la nuit
qu'ils agissent ou pas moi j'aime semi
dur
moi je veux un perso j'aurais raté mais
ça c'est dur à comparer fab
allez on va dire qu'il aurait raté aussi
il est pas bien fab
1 mais je sais pas dans quelles
dispositions mentales et dépôts ça en
fait tu joues l'autre et qu'ils essaient
f 4g si ce
n'est quand même pas mal quoi ya pas de
risque ouais c'est pour ça je pense
qu'il va trouver ok tu voi autre voie
que c'est très prometteur était
peut-être pas sûr à 100% alors à moins
de tout bien voir jusqu'au bout
voilà c'est à un doute
tu choisi l'autre bon bah y'a pas de
doute non mais c'est fort ce que fait
une épaule on se tourne c'est vraiment
pharand
il n'y a pas de doute
non mais
c'est beau mais je vous le meilleur coup
magnifique un de la pardonnez pas ok ou
moins que ce soit une belle partie
coccyx gagnent juste qu'ils pillent
bonne foi une coupe aph
bon maintenant 400 jeux pas nos pages de
fiat là je vais tempo c'est tout c'est
pas des saints qui va lui arriver là
quand tu perds g5 tu perds la maison oui
faut le faire faut perdre en cinq coups
si jamais trouve tous les coups et sinon
c'est la chance
bref quatre ans ferme accueille tout à
fait qu'ils disent à messages vont vite
mais il va se sacrifier un vote c'est le
truc ça va ouvrir
regardez vannes vers le roi blanc
mais quatre faut le faire façon même
s'il y a qu'à les prendre façon quoi
d'autre tu peux pas laisser kf4 segan
trop simplement il faut le forcer à
gagner en trouvant des coûts et et au
mans dans une pièce et peut-être se
tromper et puis s'ils se trompent pas
bah bravo nippo bonne partie et puis
c'est tout quoi d'autre et quand les
gens disaient dans le chatt heures que d
un terrain comme ça c'est pas formateur
pour ali reza moi je pense le contraire
pense qu'il vaut mieux foire est
complètement comme il le fait pour pour
vraiment repartir d'une page blanche
quoi
toujours pensé qu'il valait mieux
ça se passe mal ça se passe vraiment mal
que c'est pas à une mauvaise chose en
fait
webb enfin
je sais pas mettez jamais contents mais
au moins tu sais qu'il faut vraiment
tout changer quoi c'est cool je sais pas
s'il doit tout changeait pas en fait je
sans toi je connais pas tout son équipe
et tout ça ici ça n'a pas du tout marché
mais ce que si tu faisais la même près
pas de jouer dans deux semaines cette
salle est mieux machin voilà ça a été
catastrophe bon ça va le cacher
gerald il faut prendre des bonnes
décisions peut-être après une fois joué
un peu plus ça pourrait me faire mal ou
des choses comme ça je sais qu'il en a
un défaut il a pris une grosse fessée
compte my nuit s'il revient
faut mettre en avant comme sa prestation
il revient encore plus avec la tuerie
larbaud c'est probablement il revient
avec laquelle il a fait piètre quand on
regardait le match l'an dernier on
n'était pas persuadé que c'était pas
retraite
ils regardent maxime
pim il revient championnat du monde de
blitz jimmy gagné reprend une petite
claque avec les grands prime il revient
fort tu vois hélas l'iresa il est jeune
et du coup tu peux pas faut ça tiens ça
te motive à retravailler tu dis ouais en
fait j'étais numéro deux mondial mais
bon c'était n'était pas assez fort et ça
te donne envie de hockey il faut
retravailler faut repartir de l'avant il
faut mais ça va il faut faire quoi c'est
sa mégère c'est bien ce sport de haut
niveau c'est jamais rien et à qui tu
travailles tout le temps tout se remet
toujours en question et
admirateurs jeunes à cet âge là c'est
formateur
rend fou
il a fait les deux pattes il a perdu son
match derrière bim il a peut-être gagné
huit matches sur 10 ou neuf matches sur
dix
bah oui mais je suis retravailler les
bases les matins en un an deux ans trois
les maths de l'escalier enfin
on arrive à être dur à prendre
car
il est très tranquille en train de
l'écraser dû dire
écoute
on ne boxe pas dans la même catégorie
petit
le gouffre les sépare ouais peut-être
que le gouffre s'est encore agrandie
ouais non c'est moi je trouve ces
formateurs les
difficultés comme ça
mais le truc oui quoi
ce dont je suis sûr c'est qu'il a
travaillé à la raison pour préparer ce
temps il n'a pas chômé celle ci ils ont
mal travaillé mais pas efficace mais il
n'a pas fait le fainéant mais justement
donc je pense qu'il ya déjà c'est
toujours un peu dur à accepter ce match
n'a rien foutu s'est dit ouais bon ok
j'ai fait le con je vois je bosse ou
quoi là en fait ils
baissent a pas marché ils n'ont pas pris
les bonnes décisions jean sérien soit
mauvais choix dans les ouvertures mal
cible les adversaires mal le mal fait de
ne pas jouer et à pratiquer de pas se
mettre en condition de jouer des
tournois parties lentes officiels eux je
sais pas mais un truc qui a pas les
intrus car oui mais pas le manque de
travail et donc du coup ça veut dire que
tu as la capacité de travail je crois
qu'il a le numéro de baky
oui
donc la solution elle me paraît simple
en fait passer un coup de fil à bas qui
irait frère je suis occupé désolait est
là tu dis merde rappelle quand tu es
libre
téléphone de baky qui doit beaucoup
sonné en ce moment
avec abdel baqi bas ainsi mais bon les
enchères vont monter un team qui doit se
dire va falloir que je fasse un gros
chèque pour garder vaki bas qui est sur
les tablettes
baky dif
ni qui harcèle le pressent pour des
conseils
et mais c'est
franchement si vous perdez peuvent
m'appeler je sais faire
rené pot-de-vin de son carré ben en fait
il ne donne pas vraiment il va récupérer
b2 taper sur ces trois taper sur des cas
taper sur f qu'à taper sur deux et genre
sur food et deux pour un peu tout
colmatée mais on peut quand même prendre
en c3 un prix c'est trop a pris ces
trois et d'adoption pour l'égalité
et à tous qui tombe
mais en fait ce soir peut-être pas de
régime express juste grand format sur
cette partie parce qu'en fait cette
partie elle va tout tout exprès si fier
quoi
en fait elle fut le tournant en fait ça
fait des autres partis donc plus
d'intérêt à côté quasiment
tue pas ce que tu en penses beau plus ou
moins bastien ou gouffran 24 mai à
tourcoing f4 mais ça a quand même
problématique à la fin on va reprendre
vous prendra le pion b2 aussi en l'air
et s'il est blanc jus de bouleau rouabah
viennent de perdre un pion et
la g5 qui saute
il faut prendre est prié de s'assoir
brûle un cierge et espère là un miracle
mais c'est beau quand même avoir fait
une machin h4 g4 effigie 1h20 et se
prendre ça et réfléchir ce que t'as pas
vu kf4 fait toujours en boulettes tu
joues pas moins bien ah non c'est
catastrophique va l'aborder
pire qu'hier peut-être rien on a dépeint
des
saisons c'est de l'autodestruction ce
qui fait ouais je sais juste pas son
niveau de jeu est bon bah ils s'auto
détruit voilà ils s'abattent comme ils
savent qu'ils vont plus gagner du temps
ils s'abattent sabbath
il s'auto puni quelque part je sais pas
ce qu'il fallait faire un truc comme ça
ils sabotent ses candidats
c'est une vraie femme et rios
savate leurs notes classiques on les
mecs savent qu'ils vont pas gagner mais
ça va je dis mais c'est en fait c'est ça
en plus
ils arrivés là bousculé l'arbitré
on est obligé de s'excuser c'est fini un
coup de taser
je vous prie f4 donc mon bas dans mon
premier 2 va arriver
et c'est retenir un tan
grands pas de douche
en fait depuis deux semaines il arrivait
sur l'échiquier il a sué
alors je suis là à 3h du mat est conviée
triple à
il joue bull est sûre bullet
je travaille sur mon gars ont su travail
on a fait sonner l alarme de l'hôtel à 3
heures du matin jusque là c'est allé les
amis jusque là
monsieur me dire ventes en espagne j'ai
pas de passeport
dans le
soir en voiture
on part en route
évoquant en autriche jusqu'à madrid
c'est vous tuerons refaire toute la
vidéo de mettre lyon
ludwig aurait été content de ce moment
même sa paire côté français n'est pas là
il est venu faire le résumé de la partie
ou pas il faut plus rien au fait
il a mis le truc sur twitter ou même pas
je serai
je crois pas
non
il y en a qui sont en roue libre
est le licenciement le oui oui
ah bah oui
oui j'oubliais sur la plage en sandales
étoile troy a tout repensé 3d oui à
kayes premier théâtre et prendre c3
c3 défend rien pour être à défendre même
kailash 4 fourche à 2.93 tu as trop de
bons coups ne
suffisent plus pour essence en crever
c'est hilarant sur jaton cajac coup
logical ces magnifiques en fait
conseil qui va se parler vrai il a joué
sur sur l'it chasse 1
335 partie
de minuit à 5h 45 du mat
ding a vendangé fini tu bats il n'était
pas complètement gagnant à il est
peut-être foutu warwick ont à faire
poite simone
bas ça peut laisser caroil or cette
courbe fois je suis tombé on n'a pas vu
le temps mais j'avais vu en fait soit
c'était c'est quand tu étais à
frustrer
je sais pas
c'est pas clair en fait très facile à 21
4 500 bouteilles à des quatre
oies ok ok joli coup
vous via la tour des
normes faire du coaching
bah c'est pas dit qu'il la famille enfin
il peut l'avoir bien sûr mais
tu fera d'elle qu'elle prend des six
tous les
plannings c'est ce qu'il oublie assez
clair
rien de faire cette partie on va voir
passif habitent ou blanches trouve
l'enchaînement
de hache
vaches
safilo une belle nul peut-être caruana
riera jill ont signé depuis belle
lurette ok très bien radio
en résumé express ça c'est bien
siltzheim il est mort deuil m'appelle
youyous
il faut barrer dans le sac pour les gens
qui on la rêve c'est très drôle
le matin des candidats le matin
7h chance amis
on se devra rebondir
alors qu'un maxi me mets pas de 102 g de
haricots verts
yoyo qu'est ce que je peux manger et
maxime qui te fait un bout de poissons
tu mets 200 g de haricots l'a fait qu'à
radio 4
ok alors là y'a 2 kung fu dit très fort
et y attend ses quatre des huit for eric
et prend des six tours 2e deux dames eu
deux
mois aussi durs c'est vrai
finito
bref deux cavaliers f 4
au 7 e tour 6 4 c'est plus simple c'est
moins fort objections d'après leur dis
mais que
moins de trucs comme ça
après les échecs ça peut être très
bizarre il suffit avec nepogodov
maintenant qu'ils gagnent alireza il se
remet à bien jouer un coup des fois il
suffit de gagner une partie pourquoi il
fait penser à la gaffe de caruana contre
maximo grande chaise tour bucarest
maxime hyper mal et tout d'un coup ça va
regagner une partie ta caruana qui lui
file une cale en 1 sans raison et tout
d'un coup il se remet à jouer max son
sens
à tout d'un coup familles adoptantes m
moi non mais le hic c'est que xinhua
gagné une partie gain de temps et que tu
rapportes depuis
depuis c'est hier et aujourd'hui quoi
on va voir la partie
2-2 caruana après
elle fait moins n'est pas fait - le
mariole face au saumon am et le saumon
et fort un
peu de monde peut faire main contre
magnus
c'est alors du russe magnus 90 thann
urgences magners usmanee soit
des claques savoir de grizzly non
c'est même pas un saint pourçain c'est
le
fait très très mal non sur magnus
de vue de paiement baup
en fait au caire en quoi c'est beaucoup
plus fort coefficent c'est vrai que ça
je me demande c'est peut-être pour viser
g5 savait faux est cuite pourrait
sembler plus il est beaucoup moins fort
comme quoi
ça peut encore que le septet pour avoir
sur dam des deux dames d2 qui a aidé
2,4 au projet 5 à la fin mais on sait
que c'est très différent
bon après je pense au tour 6 4
ça plus l'air d'être un coup après si la
foux d'éviter coûte il a fondé 8
j'ai du mal à y croire s'il sort début
des trucs tanit non mais il a vraiment
joué en fait être un jeu c'est pas du
mal à y croire ou pas c'est que ça a eu
lieu
presque à roanne holding ce serait sympa
russie bastia pas magnus après jeu match
en finale du ronde aura forcément moins
de saveur mais par contre a annoncé que
le conte le deuxième des candidats
ce que j'aime pas d'expliquer pourquoi
depuis plusieurs jours non je t'aime pas
ça sera le nom alors faire comme dit
vlad si manu s'arrête complètement les
échecs à ça fait sens je pars et est du
toc non mais s'ils arrêtent pas en fait
ça veut dire que le tout le cycle de
championnat du monde est claquée au sol
ça tu complètement leur truc en fait il
veut détruire leur cycle il a plus aucun
intérêt si magnus continuer à jouer mais
qui joue plus le match championnat du
monde tu es obligé de faire un
changement parce que ça assez grave en
france voire en fait c'est comme un mais
c'est comme si au tennis à l'été tu as
tes joueurs phares qu'ils vont les
grands chênes mon sens ballack bah oui
mais non mais ça tu ton sport en fait
c'est à dire que tu as un problème
global dans ton sport ouais mais tu es
profite que transport a plus grand que
les joueurs et puis bah venez pas jouer
et marquer dans les grands chelems la
foule sera contente
mais là pour les échecs ça va être le
cas puisque tu sais très bien comment
que tout est tellement incohérent que ça
pour les échecs ça va pas marcher
ça de vrai mais pour les échecs ça va
pas marcher ça tue tout leur cycle
qui réforme les échecs globalement ce
qui doit faire depuis 50 ans en fait
mais qui s'y met une bonne fois pour
toutes ce qu'ils arrêtent de propriété
si le mec veut jamais jamais championne
du monde
a joué plus de matches mais je veux dire
ça fait des vrais des vrais circuits en
fait tu peux plus être lui même rang
mondial ce jour là tu peux être numéro
un mondial est pas champion du monde au
tennis arrêts de jeu les grands chênes
si tu veux tu seras plus numéro on s'en
bat les couilles entre guillemets basse
vallée de parler ici aussi directe en
aide aux échecs qui peut être numéro un
mondial en jouant une partie paraît
jeudi rebattu va mettre des coefficients
au tournoi tu peux
il estime que film ma chance tu veu t
pas champions du monde tu étais numéro
10 mondial et puis enfin c'est par
avocat on sait que tu es plus fort mais
tu refuse de jeter numéro 10 enfin comme
au tennis tu joues pas les grands
chelems
et tu peux aussi faire le fameux truc
quand on part d'essayer de consommer de
saison pour un super truck fin de saison
qui est celle titre comme ça et
peut-être magnus très pas content ça
d'ailleurs mais bon si en fin de séance
lundi ce point de pas moins de cinq ans
après magnus il essaie de réformer en
son sens en faisant son circuit à lui un
message de comprends tout à fait mais en
fait ça décrédibilise complètement tout
le cycle de championnat du monde s'ils
refusent de jouer
ouais mais bon parce que tu dois tout
changer parce qu'un mec un jour te fait
ça bien sûr tout ne va pas tout changer
parce qu'un jour avec toi te fais ça tu
dois tout changer parce que le circuit
n'intéresse absolument personne que ça
fait zéro hype et qu'il ait pas juste
sportive mandat mais ça ils vont pas non
mais j'ai en fait c'est pour ça que tu
dois changer est en fait le fait que
magnus puisse refuser de jouer c'est un
symptôme de la maladie
c'est pas magnus la maladie c'est le
format qui est la maladie donc juste
si tu dis oui bon il ya ce symptôme
arrêté on va donner un petit doliprane
tu auras plus symptômes mais la maladie
elle est toujours là hh tu caches donc
tu peux cacher mettre sous le tapis
faire jouer le premier le deuxième et
faire ce que tu veux mais en fait la
maladie elle est là et si elle n'est pas
traitée ben alaoui selsouli barriac en
question afin créer son pc à la fidh a
continué son truc et puis denis la
bassée cards off le champion puis voilà
mais bon vous voyez bien qu'ils avaient
déjà imprimé à l'époque oui mais avaient
ils n'ont pas réglé ils ont foutu soult
à pied le problème oui mais j'ai
régleront grèce et sur ses gambettes la
maladie elle est toujours là et ça fait
toujours ainsi que des lille 20 et
géronte eu les échecs à petit feu et peu
à peu papa mais en fait c'est juste
qu'un monet faut quelqu'un porte sa
paire de baguettes faut soit que la
finition très forte et que la fidh
chaussures des joueurs oui mais pourquoi
sinon ça va exploser avec un circuit
dans tous les sens pour que la fuite
soit au dessus des joueurs focale et le
public avec lui et avec des formats
comme ça elle n'aura pas géré par la
queue pour être au dessus des joueurs il
faut une légitimité quelques pas et là
elle n'a pas de parader forme a donc
tort je sais pas les galons dans le sens
où ils ont eux toujours là oui mais
enfin il ya deux pelletier regard fasher
au bout d'un an ils ont eu le winx
gambeat le machin ils ont rien fait et
regarde la fia ils ont fait plein de
faim peu importe mais à mon avis ça peut
faire complètement tout péter
et ce sera enfin ça pourrait être bien
mais j'ai peur qu'en fait ça tue encore
plus notre sport malheureusement alors
que de base c'est bien
après a voir ça comme une aubaine pour
réformer mais ils vont pas d'une il va
pas le faire ouais mais clairement fait
savoir fin mai
mais
ouais
je trouvais carlson propose aucune
alternative alors je suis d'accord avec
toi tonus prononcent mais au bout d'un
moment il n'y a pas que à 40 1 j'ai pas
il ya des gens c'est leur métier aussi
de faire ça
s'il a déjà dit des efforts magogois je
sais plus qui disait mais des fois il
dit des trucs
mais oui là le problème c'est
sens pour moi magnus soirée comme jeudi
sera symptômes et pas la maladie
n'est juste 20 ans fait alors son avis
profonde pourquoi il veut pas jouer s'il
joue pas
parce qu'on fait ok tu vas faire ton
match est un grand champion du monde
ça fera un nouveau type de gagner
je sais pas où est le problème profond
d'aller jouer un match en fait
même si grand joueur qui a déjà battu
toutes sont très favoris
non mais là aussi tout je comprends mais
sinon tu prends ta retraite enfin c'est
à venir oui tu as des sportifs bien de
bordj arrêté assez tôt de tennis
même si zoug on te prend sa retraite qui
fait tu dis ouais si l envie de jouer
encore au foot il peut aller gambader
encore quelques années et faire du bien
à plein des équipes bons mais ils
arrêtent parce que oui à cette étude que
machin sage en temps mais juste art et
théâtre
est en fait à être tous les tournois
contre tous les joueurs de haut niveau
pourra quand même se préparer quand même
s'entraîner quand même faire des grosses
près parce que quand tu as de prendre
des bons qui en fait son affaire tout le
même effort mais juste pas joué ce match
là
bon alors qu'est la fidh s'énerve elle
te reste on casse mon fils tu refuses de
particuliers aux cycles
ça va pas ingéré c'est ce serait
tellement un autre symptôme d'un
problème grave non mais ça serait comme
comme l'uefa voulait faire s'ils
jouaient en
truck de ligatures écrit
le sz tu fais ça tu veux une coupe
d'europe normale et machin puis c'est
tout
il est plutôt rare ces quatre y paraît
mais c'était le web enfin que
j'attendais mois alors là on le voit pas
un retour c'est quatre jours avait
échoué trois ok le jeu s'est vite c'est
bien
allez on va voir si ces athlètes faire
nul en fait bizarrement sa tête faire
[ __ ] angers 5 tours bien d'un point 2
juste parce que ce n'est pas lui suffire
puisque n'est possible il suffit
qu'elle vous peut-être pas
de titre adore prendre quatre dames
prend des cinq je sais pas quoi
bons fous j'ai 5 est attendu en tout cas
ici
des maigret moins de 15
ça peut faire nul
et à trop intérêt en fait n'est pas
mais bon je suis pas super beau parent
bon là ça devrait faire une
annonce à jouer qui aura l'effet qu'il
est un guide a vu le truc alors
ok bah il passe une bassine et pau fait
nul et qui à roanne à gagner encore un
petit enjeu
ça se peut qu'il est là nul
né peu
après c'est quand même c'est tourbains
damas de toi tu en prends des 4 va faire
dame prend
à de si tu es fou projets venus et dame
prend des 5
oui c'est quoi leur retard matériel tu
ne tournes qualité quoi
est faite la tène tournoi mettait déjà
cinq noms pour la toile et pièces hockey
donc fou g5
bien damas deux
obligé de faire tout reprend 1,2 pour
prendre déjà reprendre la tour et j'ai
33 c'est qu'il était contre 4 pions
aller contre trois pions va prendre des
six mois ça ne sais pas quoi as tu
décidé d'ailleurs
les bons tours hausse
7,5
caisse est pas terminée terminé à ces
trois pions pour égaliser quoi
tu as des petites chambres deux nuls
encore mais oui mais oui il va y aller
c'est qu'il ya pas trop de risques
après tout un truc organisé
pour info tour tomber un à deux ans pour
un 3 pts
aura deux tours des quatre
une pièce pour l'instant bientôt 2 est
mignon
ça j'aime bien mais il va pas faire mais
j'aime bien les frontières
ça revient un peu au même au final mais
un peu la sécurité de
l'état gation très bizarre avant
ça il fera pas ça il fera pas il fera
pas
jouer la sécurité n'est pas il n'a pas
joué le truc le plus fort et le plus
direct mais oui ça se comprend vu sa
situation de tournois en fait 30 0%
risque de perdre non mais tu te dis je
vais le tuer parce que ce que je vais te
tuer au pire tournage fedama dos dames
b2 finul déjà je dois réfléchir ap c'est
peut-être un truc quand même et maria et
tu te décides à ce moment là
c'est nul ils sont fous bah oui c'est
pas les cinq points d'autres différences
qui vont le l'embêter lui veut juste
gagner six candidats et voilà le très
clair et vrai
tours ben
ouais mais mieux et une bonne opération
apport des pourris
clairement
on a parti tu demandes y fait nul on dit
caruana gagnant
on était des deux autres
mais se voir ici imposition yves hayez
mieux gagnant c'est un grand mot gagné
un grand mot à lille et mieux
ouais matisse le truc c'est que magnus
annoncé son qui j'aurai pas mais enfin
il annonce qu'il veut tant que ce n'est
pas officiel
à moi je sais pas quoi enfin ils croient
pas complètement tiendra pas moins on
était quand même plus sûrs de leur
premier tu as de faire deuxième et et
prier le ciel que le champion en titre
viennent pas se présenter
voici serait probablement de loin pas
facile à voir marit
sait bien peu y aura une finale entre le
premier le deuxième donc bas selon qui
finit deuxième à priori c'est une course
entre ding
caruana et un canadien
mais comme disait moi je suis plutôt
contre ça
moi j'aimerais que vainqueurs des
candidats deviennent champions du monde
à ce moment là leur part sur notre cycle
parce qu'en fait il en a vu caruana
depuis deux trois jours prendre
d'énormes risques il faut savoir très
bien et pau ça n'a pas marché l'effet
0,5 sur trois en fait si justin jacente
aura sa chance deuxième ça pouvait
suffire il allait finir 2e l'argent fait
et
bien fait des règles sont pas claires
avant le temps biba faut finir premiers
devraient conduire abbas était deuxième
ces montres pêche et si tu sais pas ça
ne fait un sans-faute en ajustant fait
avec deuxième peut suffire ya plein de
mecs serait pas suicidé d'être rapporte
compte n'est peau quand il à 50% il va
pas donc en fait tu apprends d'un
classement qui a lieu parce que tu as
donné des règles et tu respectes plus le
deal quoi tu te rends le contrat et
c'est n'importe le prince c'est
grotesque que sportivement tout et
prothèses façon là on est dans du
grotesque donc rempilé plus sens du
grotesque dont du business
sera démontable donc après bah oui été
déçus de voir ton championnats du monde
doivent être empire taille nouveau
champion taillefer l'cie le cycle et
puis après tu auras un train après celle
ci le problème du fait qu'il ya un que
ce soit une fois tous les deux ans ces
trucs là au lieu d'une fois tous les ans
par l'emporter
60 - c'était plus logique fisher revient
pas plus cher vient pas car peuvent
champions puis si tous ne sont pas les
repêcher corps se taillader retient vu
le match qu'il a joué plus tard
d'ailleurs
il peut appeler une fois mais il ya au
canal avantage à répéter pour
s'approcher du 40e étant donné qu'il a
une telle avance à la pendule soit on
reprend des quatre projets pour le bien
qui est clairement la décision on va
dire et chicken vont pas relancer le bon
coup après pour gérer le tournoi il
pourrait très bien se contenter nul et
complexe
s'il voit ses chances
normalement
c'est parti pour le tournoi n'ont pas
normalement et
pour la partie soit n'est pas contente
de nuls soit laissé de gagner c'est déjà
entre les mains de dépôt et revoici
essayer de gagner il a quand même un bel
avantage
quasiment imperméable enfin justin moins
de fans énorme gaffe ensuite donc en
firent ou la joue plus que pour faire
nul
complexe pour après le motif d'espoir
c'est quand même que les candidats
féminin ils ont ils ont une bonne
formule donc peut-être que ça va ça va
évoluer dans le bon sens quand même le
motif d'espoir
des points à mon avis va faire annuler
en fait je sais pas pourquoi je sens
qu'il ya une tête de quelqu'un qui fait
nul
non
pour le tournoi c'est tellement logique
de faire nul
il est pragmatique depuis le début
après juste si tu veut punir ton
adversaire bien fait ou match et qu'eux
ils trouvent plus jamais le coût de sa
vie tu
[Musique]
rigoles ou quoi
juste tu veux dire tu as fait trop quoi
oui
c'est plus un
bar entre je compte moi et je vois pas
tempo l'ouverture pas un simple toit je
m'en suis pas trop ravi qu en fait
mais
enfin le vase et le bon coup aux échecs
ouais j'espère pour lui qu'il va s'en
mordre les doigts parce que signifie de
gaza après j'en fais tu vires ci fait
nul enfin je pense le ton est plié en
fin de vie mais bon prête c'est la bonne
décision échec très clairement c'est le
bon coup il une très bonne partie n'est
pas pour l'instant je vois pas pourquoi
tout d'un coup j'aurais plus une bonne
partie
c'est beau ce que même là il n'a pas
tempo c'est extraordinaire en fait
les marrons faire tout reprend dames le
reprendre la tour et tu
es fou 3 3
était de moins pour trois quatre pions
on vous +3 que 4
ha ouais très bel avantage noir
normalement gagnant même un mais
on va finir
fou prend des quatre bains il peut y
apprendre et 4 mai après dame prend des
cinq ces cinq pions pour la tour déjà et
le truc c'est qu'on va récupérer une
pièce parce que tout est rose qui h
théâtre
juste d'être
mon père dans une pièce sur et le roi
est tout nu enfin rempli pions quoi
ces arbres une pulsion il ya plus de
pions on pourrait la voir
avec autant de pièces très chic
mines ont fait tilt of heroes aussi en
lui jouant beaucoup de finale au début
il a fait tout reprend à de vraies
peut-être la sauver en fait gestion
donné peut faire qu'il peut peut-être la
sauver en mêlée peau il veut gagner là
bas mais je vais faire du féminin a
reculé plus gérer dans le dans la phase
d'avant
j'en rêvais
c'est toi c'est un tout un truc qui me
peine y avait des toutous un non-choix
pas
déjà 18 heures le temps avance
je vivrai la vie bref mais j'ai pas fais
tout tout le génie ans mais je retiens
tout doute
on va attendre un dépôt qui continuent à
clic clic clic et qui cela est fou prend
des infos prendre 3 qui est prend des
six ont alors la position n'est possible
quoi il se lève à tous les coups mais
après ça travaille cauchemar c'est quand
il se lève beaucoup c'est qu'il est un
peu stressé
business tout le temps tout en serez
seul mât mais là ils savent un peu plus
qu'à l'habitude et ça me donne envie
d'aller chercher un petit shooter ah oui
c'est un jeu bien
donc il va nous
allons la déception c'est en reste car
il sera pour toi
ouais bon depover food rend fou entre
sont claires
elle devrait prendre ce pion
enchaînement est bon ton re5 sûrement
tour ici
oh
mercy
et le coup de fouet refait les maracas
ouais
on est très heureux non ah bah oui
me dis qu'ils trouvent que des portraits
sur un
ballon et 13h pour l'avoir vu en vrai
l'an dernier être en face de lui sur
l'échiquier
oui non oui d'après du fou ce qu'on
répression et que tout reprendre ainsi
prend du fou a priori vaut mieux faire
tours au 7e tour 5 jusqu'à s'attaquer
hyper-v sattel sz pas sûr qu'ils gagnent
encore
mon tour cette semble logique
bon traitement scream 4 qui prend des
saints qui ne tient plus de pions
je peux vous fournir du combustible et
amis du crunch pas mal aussi de kombucha
chanter ton bonheur à carreaux la
carioca acariens
new by
fede tous comme moi
[Musique]
n'oublie
pas son lac à
huy
ouais
tu bluffes marteau n'irait
sont bons un
garde du corps passé le choc bouclier
est priée de quoi
c'est un peu un sol dur boy
ligne du prince à tes yeux
ça a été un beau combat entre sa
longueur boys et abderrahmane avis ce
profil way n'est peut-être pas demain
peut-être qu'ils vont te mettre en fin
de saison ou quoi maintenant je pense
qu'il ya encore deux trois épisodes en
avant la fin j'ai pas besoin de saison 2
épisode de la saison 10 normalement mais
saint gilloise or
et ça peut être une star light ambulante
qui fait
ouais enfin prochain à bord mais on
dirait enfin ouais je fais pas le poids
six autres un coup d'oeil c'est fini
quoi
ou même seul gars boys je pense même que
bouchard avec s'est énervé je pense qu'à
aucune chance mais
sans sauvegarde boy s'associe à un
blindé à la fin de la saison
s'ils sont très très énergiques ont
nouveau que je sais pas à qui il ya une
histoire de
pas moi je vois l'armée en fait tout un
ils en ont marre de ces super héros qui
font n'importe quoi je veux ramener un
peu d'ordre peut-être être un super
héros contre contre humain quoi
annoncer qu'à la salle lur bouyer
hollander i se réunir est
exo dipl
[Rires]
dix hommes lander l'afp l'armée
américaine je suis pas sûr ça dépend les
armes qu'ils ont tués ils ont compris
sur des des boucliers de ouf jean
sarment fatwa
de [ __ ] qui connaissent ils ont mal
fait d'accord avec des cartouches mois
le frenchy
il n'est pas français du tour attend en
fait voir c'est on va voir un allez on
va se renseigner on mène l enquête
d'origine française
non mais vraiment quand j'entends parler
des petites phrases française
mais j'adore cet acteur ça sonne pas
français quoi
l'israélien il jouait dans food faudra
faudra mathieu mathieu il est pour les
séries tu peux croire
je pensais le plus grand expert de série
il s'appelle thomas cap on
la pense qu'à ça sonne français comme
un cappone
mais non il est pas français non mais ça
se voit qu'il a appris par coeur qui
c'est beau je n'ai pas la langue de
faire ce qu'il fait mais à l'intonation
l'accent
après il joue très très bien fraudent oh
oui bien sûr mon perso
mon coeur mon coeur
fait ce qu'il veut ça va jamais recteur
globalement le casting est excellent
même hewit il est très bien parce qu'en
fait tu as envie de le détester il est
fait pour ça il me saoule joli coup
d'oeil et on voit que demain mais il est
fait pour être détesté en fait bon y en
avoir quand vous êtes acheteur
c'est comme et il aime bien dans les
antres guillemets gentil mettre un mec
que tu
[Musique]
sais comme king geoffrey
porges avec afat en quatre saisons quand
même qu enfin vraiment vas-y toi foetus
a fait
mais bon ok bah oui il est gentil et
l'eau c'est juste une année normale et
d'arthur remarquent-ils avec l'actrice
qui est très mignonne c'est fait exprès
ou quoi du coup depuis le déteste ça de
la mode
pourquoi lui que
pour toi tél
oui demandeurs ces deux acteurs phares
et
je vous traduis mendy puis joue vraiment
bien on met tout sur votre âge et pas
trop de critiques à faire mais non midi
pied tellement il n'y aurait pas
d'augmentation
que je regarde
ouais mais bon enfin c'est comme
beaucoup de films majeurs stade est
mauvais acteur
dans ma tête je veux dire c'est que j'ai
pas envie que le personnage meurt celui
ci plus la même et inquiète par sa
grandeur à mon avis ce type l'acteur
joue super bien mais moi aussi je prie
le super bien mais grc et joue super
bien le gars que tu as envie vraiment de
dtcc le coup
et même que personnage écrit avec son
truc avec son genre d'église ou qui rend
complètement coups
de canon ce type à bajaur d'église de
super héros de chez pas quoi
mais bon le trip poulpe lui plutôt
parce que black noir c'est le frère de
stan edgar très possible
j'aime réfléchi mais
ça peut
b trois
enfants son pion en d5
il veut peut-être un petit chipeau 2
préserve cette décision c'est un truc
comme ça
qu'est ce qu'en dit la turbine est
de fouiller 3
alors pas très fan de même moins 4 70
après tout c'est simplement
sur un coup comme les pros 9,7 de dole
trois textes ont soulevé trois
ans qu'on fait en montrant ses 4e et 5e
ils ont tort
b2g ces cinq cavaliers vii pour 3 total
de 3,3 soit je prends 80 chats ou bon
t'as pas de chipset en fait surtout c5
et si tu fait qu'il prend beyssade du
coup
plutôt truc logique de l'autre côté il
te dit
foulée 6 mai sur des six afu celle ci
soit ok ah oui et tu menaces tour 3 oui
tu menaces tout en fait resto mais ok
quel point c'est assez dur mais ça c'est
dur mais là tu menaces tout
quand même pas tous restent rares à
karachi 4 est trouvable mais a pas
facile pour après a parfait ses 5 qui
est clairement le coup mais d'après
leurs dires
la preuve c'est que tout effort
ce que je veux dire c'est même fou g4
non juste
ou pas
après calibrage et 3 par exemple ouais
t'as pas de case c'est con
non mais je vais faire un coup comme wii
fit ce qui pèse tout un soupçon de mardi
il va bien
oui oui oui évidemment machin est
donc
besoin de 3 pouces et 5 près tu peux la
voir peut-être
sonné pour trouver un accueil écoute
c'est moins vrai faire nul mais c'est
moins deux capteurs
ça peut jouer très longtemps ça ouais il
va jouer très longtemps
tourner à droite à gauche il n'y aura
pas de bay arena ce soir
l'ifab i
believe you il est mieux
parce que floor opposé il va voir la
taxation jouer en tout point il fout des
deux pouces et 3 il va sera mené la
bataille vers le roi peut-être
ramener la dame essaie de casser les
cachent quatre jours je sais parfum
[Musique]
data qu'il a son petit mur des 3/4 de
foule s est alors qu'ils sont faut être
fort donc c'est aussi simple que ça
al'avantage après quel point ça va être
facile de réaliser ou pas ça va défendre
en face être compliqué mais
mais bon il a les avantages
et il traîne je pense qu'ils les mains
ou pas
non
non mais on croit mourir
cardiaque
presse comme ça peut-être la retrouver
un peu de donneurs de
fait le truc juste originaire fois
traitées avec 110 km la tête la première
donc juste un cran
borloo cela n'en fait rien on va dire
donc il s'est fait justice voilà
vous avez vous avec l'espagne c'est
grave non mais enfin alors à discuter
quoi
mais en fait en plus d'épisodes il a été
appelé une semaine fin jensen
site amazon tu l'as vu toi + moi j'y
peux rien et puis si tu l'as pas bah
c'est que tu regardes pas donc
bah oui je te rappellera pas de façon
assez pas
ce qui est un peu de renfort
de plus rien 1 on parle de couple au
début on se fait incendier on ne parle
de séries ça va pas bien on dit plus
rien ok on va faire un seul silencieux
c'est beaucoup mieux quoi
s'affoler quoi enfin chardon juste je
regarde la série dans trois semaines tu
vas pas te rappeler de
bah oui
mais moi j'ai déjà eu des trucs nous
sommes regardés vrai bon c'est
tout de suite plus rien fait rien bien
sûr que non
a eu certes essor
des mémos des bourricots en fait j'aime
beaucoup faire ce qu'on veut rodez est
morte je suis bien
et puis bon après c'est aussi la nature
du stream a on a des tournois où il se
passe par exemple un jeu c'est pas les
parties sont longues et on ne sait plus
trop de quoi parler aux pédales
emboîtement 5
honnêtement je pensais pas trop dur pour
un
tel effort
nouvelles de mazet bah ouais des
nouvelles je mange avec la 3g va faire
un tour en fait elle a tout perdu il a
fait que des first mais c'est pas grave
c'est pas en danger pour son classement
il est reparti chez lui
il passe une petite semaine avant
d'enchaîner avec la bundesliga
est arrivé tard que le sol oui voilà
qu'est ce que je dois te dire ou pas je
sais pas je dis rien à mon avis
on est bien
dire oui non ni fausse et 5 ou mousse
boyle et la partie attention
ouais ouais mais c'est vrai qu'à lire
les halles avec ces deux cadeaux
mariage artois pour moi ce qui serait
rendue spoil sais si tu pirate un truc
n'est pas encore sorti il attend parle
ouais ou en parler dès le lendemain la
se fait déjà une semaine quand même ceux
qui sont vraiment fan fan de la série
après je peux de spoil ce qu'il ya dans
ma boutique blick stream shop
est superbe volée superbe ou d'y aller
t-shirt
clic au hasard et si tu veux vraiment de
faire spoil par toi même et voir
vraiment tout ce qu'il ya dans la
boutique avec les porte-clés et tous les
voir fait point d'exclamation shop tu
vas sur le site ouverture officielle de
la boutique en fait c'est qu'aujourd'hui
mais c'est pas aujourd'hui et tu peux
aller sur la boutique en cliquant sur le
lien qui a dans le chat et tu peux même
te laisses poil irl en les achetant du
coup il arrive chez toi et tu vas
pouvoir les déballer et les ouvrir et
les essayer c'est pour bientôt spoil
donc ça parle vraiment academy ouais
j'ai tout regardé j'ai vu la dernière
saison je ne dirai rien
moi je peux dire si j'aimais pas aimé
peut-être je sais pas si je dois dire ça
pourrait marcher parce qu'en fait ça le
[Musique]
ccri mode blanc attend
le lien ouais important
et sûr
ouais si on a sauvé cinq tours prend b
saturn à ce tour 3 tu n as peut-être des
carénages 4 avec des robes ont fait une
menace fin ça soit pas y'a rien à dire
cette partie en fait la
bédéiste sous-estimé voilà c'est ça
entre deux mondes qui voulaient défiler
chaque attaque le roi tacle qui avait
sept leroy bougera bouge et on remet ça
merci au revoir
et donc ça c'est un problème
jeridi si ce retour on retrouvera avec
le full hd 3d
et puis c'est tout en fait et surtout
avec toi et cars et 10 h 4 fourchette et
voilà bon
du coup trop de menaces trop de
problèmes roy trop faibles plutôt
branché
je pense pas qu'il va abandonner
pas
il suffit pas il va cliquer quoi un coup
de mou trois coups en
aura plus
mais pau quasi sûr de gagner après
aujourd'hui bah ouais parce qu'en fait
c'est un peu dommage que si caruana unac
avait gagné c'est possible qu'un des
deux gagne ça revient à 1 point à trois
rondes c'est déjà beaucoup
et demi surtout qu'il a deux blancs je
crois notre sol des petites nul
bien solide bagage je pense pas qu'ils
tentent non
à la dernière joute qui
remporte
avec les blancs
besoins
des surprises a écrit jean
dépôt est très solide joue très bien
je vois pas comment ça peut lui échapper
un
je sais pas pourquoi je vendrais se
mettre à faire que des bulles alors
qu'il joue si bien
qu'ils prennent garde une peut-être
parce que ça peut arriver et les mecs en
face c'est pas des manches mais bon même
écart où je pense pas qu'ils jouent
demain non pas il va jouer normalement
des formules
[Musique]
mais carouge pour certains le
pragmatique en disant ok peut-être
second ça qualifie peut être pas à 100
il est trop loin j'ai parvenir donc si
jamais par miracle à deuxième place
qualifie vas-y je joue pour la deuxième
place
exactement
alors je sens que nous demandent si
les bois sa revanche contre magnifique
il ne me connaît pas de gaffe
donnez-vous bas à pas mal enfin je sais
pas combien
en fait c'est un peu le poème de dépôt
c'est que des fois il tilt silas on
m'accepte jamais de cogner il dure à
battre pour n'importe qui
thomson inclut
aujourd'hui demain et je pense pas parce
qu'il aura un point et demi de retard
même s'il venait à gagner au noir ce qui
est hautement improbable il serait
toujours pas favori pour la première
place alors que si fait nul il peut
jouer la deuxième place qui peut
théoriquement le qualifier je vois pas
pourquoi il irait surtout qu'il joue
bien c'est vraiment préparé sur la
berlinoise on voit qu'il n'a pas de
répertoire blé b contre 4 1 mais le
problème pour les cas où ces campus
l'année pauvres à gagner bah oui il ya
trop d'écarts il ya rien même pas si
proche si tout se passe bien mais après
il pourrait à la rigueur ne pas faire la
berlinoise essayer une espagne là si
c'est un truc qui joue un peu
en se disant qu'il annule en poche parce
qu'issues à tendre la main
bref si tu veux voir proposer nullement
faudra pas qu'ils poussent trop laid
ils ont ils pu jouer mais ouais mais
dépôts va pas sans rire les
vieux rideaux dit pour l'anniversaire de
son petit frère et mardi on est con et
je dis est ce que ça peut arriver d'ici
là bas c'est pas qui est pétri jardin
préféré sans voix mais ça peut enfin je
sais pas il ya il ya beaucoup d'envoi
qui ont été faits en fait moi je le vois
à il vient de le faire maintenant
je peux demander et quand l'anniversaire
ce mardi
tu viens de faire la commande je vais
faire inscrire mais je vais demander
à tous
chouchoutez la
voie rapide peut-être
écrire c'est beau de suivi client
d nistos
la d66 a poussé six échecs en fait à
l'heure on peut montrer que des flèches
vous ces six échecs libère la tour qui
avoue fait le cavale
échec donc sauver le roi avant le
cavalier donc ça va pas
non n'y a pas beaucoup mais j'arrive
déjà là et comme hier en fait c'est
foutu tellement mal autant qui peut même
perdre un pendule
bonne c'est que encore une fois c'est
pas que la pendule le problème
en tout cas merci on a repris les deux
bouts dit tu nous diras un retour aux
racines terroir et blanc ou le noir
foncé 4
ok
on vient de dire que ça partira qu'on
fera partir ta commande demain
normalement qu'à moins de réactifs en
plus drapeau du civic c'est beau ben oui
abbas est sérieux donc normalement ce
sera là pour le frérot
doit se faire que
l'on espère
oued ont poussé quatre il ya peut-être
plusieurs options ces drames et la tour
j'ai pas où 54 être pour aller faire des
échecs l'a45 prolonger 5
après h quatre espaces a
offert roger 3 j'imagine si tu recules
va [ __ ] fois je crois toujours trop
tard on joue cool enfin tout est cool je
pense pas
tour 3 ou sinon bah il a fait le coup
que j'avais subi une torsion n'avait
tour quatre coups mail mais tour trois
mois ça c'est le coût qui donnait envie
ce que ça coupe le roi et tu veux qu'il
valait h4
il joue tempo bah ouais il est en
confiance et 1 il écrase un
soutien aux singles aussi peut-être
aidé moi soit je crois en tout cas
mais pour le québec les frais sont
abordables il faut que tu regardes j'ai
pas les frais en tête mais si tu passes
une commande et que tu ajoutes des
choses dans le panier tu verras
normalement
je pars en tête tous les frais de
livraison du monde
et mettant automatisé femmes
se cachent
eux c'est quoi sa seconde rangée avec la
torah 2 qui n'arrête pas un peu un échec
ou deux
à ce qui est bien c'est que ça clique de
45 pour six coups caruana avec deux
minutes aussi on nous dit
ouais mais pour un coût on peut voir le
coup quoi tu sais il a bien fait le fond
ces trois comme prévu et
et il va il va travailler la position
ça réfléchit de nouveau côté néo pop
pour bien finir
colin petit tour ces trois j'aime bien
le coût de leur a dit perça
orchin
sur flu g4 là juste pour ce troisième
bien foutu quatrième bien parce que
l'idée cédé six fois
f3a mais à tort prend encore prend et
des 17 hockey joué quatre des six il te
dit qu'aller aux singles
du stop l'option de virton fois f3 tout
avec le truc fait à tour h 3o sinon ça
t'as pas mal de clics
mais en fait je comprends il veut
commencer par tous et pour ça il veut
commencer par tour ces trois
des hommes en irak genre de truc émanant
fou g4
ce que le fonds à six il est vraiment
mal et s'il était partirai pas fous les
sens et sur food pour
h33 g2 qui est h43 yeux ce qui a plutôt
rage de
professionnels tour ces trois
forces et 3 très professionnel
il devrait faire un
il me semble qu'aucun champion du monde
n'est gagné ses premiers candidats
peut-être kasparov
oui car le sel en quelque sorte mais
savait qu'il y avait des matches avant
ouais bah ouais y avait match avant
pâques rabbinique en tout cas la nuit
que les a jamais gagné
l'or avec 5 secondes vrai mais c'était
le dernier coup donc il a joué mardi
reprend et marque
cette partie va être longue et
on fera une petite baisse très long ça
va être très long et ça non ça ça va
être drôle ça peut être aussi long que
ça je pensais qu'il est plus arrivé à
affaires de 26 à 6 caruana ding termine
par nuls ces deux points d'avancé ça
c'est vraiment terminé
c'est déjà
là mais c'est déjà mais j'ai en fait là
tu fais rire et ce trois parties
chez nul à null null et
les pâtes conesa pour christophe 6 6 1
il a dû passer par des matches et battu
un smith l'a
finalement smith le fils est battu
bakar
chouity
bdf qui je crois
c'est beau c'est un beau parcours
un
espoir 20 ans anli bedja ce qui cloche
maggie smith l'a fait
mais a fait flasher trois tacles à tour
il va falloir clique d'agents un hyper
blatière de 30 c'est une éternité fab
on sait plus trop quoi vous dire
de mémoire je me rappelle pas de
candidat avec si peu de suspense à wayne
rooney pour écraser le tournant en fait
une question grave a perdu quand on est
champion
je sais pas s'il est candidat je pense
pas qu'il ait ce genre 74 il y avait
gagné 114 pour être en version finale
contre richard du calme qui s'est pas
présentée dans le car popov peut-être
aussi amener ses premiers candidats je
pense pas qui je le sais que d'avant
était trop jeune je pense
mais pas et créations à des candidats et
carlson a écrasé né pauvre est
cette fois il a beaucoup poussé creusé
que la dernière fois enfin il y avait
quand même maxime qui étaient au coude à
coude avec lui à mi parcours qui même
après quand ils jouent contre lui maxime
le bassin envers ce tournant a faim il y
avait un vrai enjeu quoi
là
là ils perdent tranquille en fait c'est
toujours bien il a toujours peur d'eux
mais alors après il avait un point et
demi de retard avant la dernière ronde
oui
non la fois oui c'était fini on en voit
la fin mais pendant un bon moment
20 petit enjeu il y avait un gros jeu
non mais après c'est aussi difficile de
dire vous avez mis maxime eko plus saïfi
rojet ou enfin ils ont joué les mêmes
tourne à fuy roja s'est qualifié maxime
n'ont donc il faut aussi rendre à fuir
au jazz café rue de jaffa donc vous d'un
moment hockey est là ils jouent mal ou
quoi mais maxime ap aurait pu se
qualifier il s'est fait éliminer par
rapport dans un match on avait enfin
un nom mais pas sur ces qualifs la fille
roule déjà été plus forts rapporte était
plus fort et il mérite dit enfin géré
par a annoncé le joueur qui sont là ils
ont pu alors plus est non alors y'a lieu
radjabov qu'on peut discuter mais bon
c'est consternant mais voilà c'est joli
il faut aux quatre sujets de maths
donc voilà yakin radja qui s'est pas
qualifié directement mais s'est
qualifiée pour les précédents et de ses
chances dans tous les coins de
qualifications il s'est pas qualifié fin
juin il faut aussi rendre l'honneur au
ceux qui ont réussi à se qualifier
puisque à priori ils sont plus fins
auraient ils ont réussi leurs
qualités comme la
coupe du monde on se plaint qui est pas
l'italie
baisse qualifiée qu'enfin se qualifie
pas c'est que a priori tu es moins forts
que ceux qui sont là c'est terminé c'est
ça a serré la main après fou ou quatre
échecs
et c'est une victoire facile de dépôt
qui écrase le tour voilà s'interrompt
pour sa peau gaschard déjà maillot jaune
et qui repart dans une côte et qui
assomme le tour ouais
[Musique]
bon très mauvaise partie d'alireza voilà
et n'est pas très bien rien à dire
il fait sa partie il a juste très bien
joué il a écrasé le tournoi alors c'est
pas encore officiel sa qualif mais
est bon j'hésite by numbers suis pas
contre m
[Musique]
oui va essayer de faire quatre nuls et
tenir on espère qu'ils en perdent une et
c'est ça peut revenir on sait pas
comment mener là en ayant plus gagner
et on est au delà de ça et hikaru enfin
je vois pas comment il peut que ça
vienne pas et fabi souhaitons vous faire
une petite pause peut-être ouais on va
faire mal et on verra ça va durer sa
femme on web mais ça va être long ça ça
peut durer encore deux heures donc
rester là tranquille on va un peu récup
on va réussir les débris que le ton
entre nous on se retrouve à tout
en les amis on est de retour mais on ne
sait plus trop quoi vous dire
honnêtement on discute à la pause avec
fab il ya plus rien à voir en fait avant
ce tournoi il est il et il est terminée
dont tu as fait le pile entre guillemets
un peu pendant la partie et on a
réellement plus grand chose à vous dire
je sais pas si vous avez des questions
quoi ça va être long et les trois
derniers jours
on fera beaucoup de pauses
one on se roule toujours on fera des
trucs intéressants aussi même
de pause par heure donc vu le nombre
d'heures qu'on a fait sans pause on peut
prendre quasiment quinze minutes de
pause par heure à partir de maintenant
quoi mais
côté qu'à roanne est en fait allusion
vous avez un seau d'eau karana non vous
permet en fait l'échiquier oui l'afp que
tous caruana c'est une bascule mais
l'échiquier c'est le kit car depuis tout
à l'heure
ouais donc on sait pas trop quoi vous
dire malheureusement ça nous ça nous
enlève la bay arena de ce soir oui les
candidats choisis autant d'audience
plus fort plus
malheureusement non mais ça pourrait en
fait
c'est waouh c'est
beau
la vie en dehors on essaie ouf la chose
c'était toi
mais tout s'est vite elle chantera
présence de fuir ou au non moi cette
faille aurait une lutte pour la première
place enfin si mais bon là en fait le
tournoi et à plus aucun intérêt quoi
après on peut s'inventer un intérêt pour
une éventuelle course à la deuxième
place qui pourrait s'avérer quelque
chose ou pas mais à la base c'est pas ça
le but des candidats c'est une heure
premier point mort
donc l'on peut s'inventer une life
fantastique qui vaille est parti pour la
seconde place
non vraiment on s'en bat l'oeil
je sais pas trop ce qu'on va faire on
peut aussi attendre tranquillement et
plus trop parler donc enfin moins parler
dans le sens où en fait on n'a plus un à
dix on a un peu c'est dur d'être
pertinent quand il ya plus rien à dire
quoi
on a tout dit quoi bon et beau j'espère
que vous avez le nos commentaires
pendant ces candidats
manuge pas suisse à deux secondes
passées vrai nom mais bon enfin on a
déjà expliqué deuxième attrape le coc
vide avant le match sera le troisième
essai par le troisième c'est enfin louis
si vous voulez mais
mais c'est pas pertinente d'un cadre est
champion on sait tous il joue pas
vraiment c'est un système de merde c'est
un système de merde mais sans dit plus
rien ça reste des parties d'échecs qui
permettent de s'améliorer enfin pied
mais je regarde pas les matchs de foot
le soir premiers jours fous tous les
matches et il se forme et ajouté une
histoire si tu veux t'améliorer tu ne
travailles tu lisais d'iwate une
adhésion
calèche est devenu grand maître témoin
oui
24 25 ans par là
alors comprendre qu'on prend
detox ft volvo cars sont les parties
ouais mais quand même c'est que celle
enfin ces six heures par jour tous les
jours et c'est au bout d'un moment
on a tout dit alors quand on est sur ma
chaîne perso si on fait un petit tour de
france au milieu où
on fait quelques pistes quelques machin
c'est possible mais là parler pendant
six heures
d'affilée on en a rien à dire en fait
presque augmenté on veut le tournant
aliéna quoi là
[Musique]
le principal et pau a tué le tournoi a
écrasé le tournoi tout simplement
michao commentaires rabbin michel elle
fait des belles c est
l envoi de la belle fiesta micha
toujours du candidat ouais je veux qu'on
te rapporte mon parti longtemps vrai
parti
crois que c'est tout
et qui radja j'ai jamais joué
ding jamais joué nespouls jamais joué
fabi jamais joué naka jamais joué
duda jamais joué vous adorez fuir en top
16 mai
et ont fait 7 et donc rapporte est ce
qu'on peut regretter l'absence de mvl
bah écoute il a perdu contre les joueurs
qui se sont qualifiés donc
fondamentalement non en fait on regrette
en tant que supporters mais sinon non
après on regarde les gens qui sont les
zones à telle heure place quoi mais oui
moi donc supporters en organique maxime
soit là où
il rapporte aussi deux fois
et fait une nulle incroyable contre
rapporte mathieu parti parti très
compliqué il avoir un mac est je crois
une nulle assez vite en 2012 voilà
mitropa cup
je connais pas la partie belle le
chercheur on a gardé à vue non n'est pas
habituel tournoi est fini c'est juste
que là on est on est assis on sait pas
trop ce qu'on regarde en fait du coup
c'est plus ça après désabusé je dirais
pas faim c'est juste que pour moi en
fait c'est comme tu regardes un truc pas
l'équipe qui a gagné comme si tu allais
la coupe du monde de foot tu viens de
regarder la finale mais voiturage pasqua
ouais mais pas après la finale perdue de
savants si ça avant
c'est un peu ça
médiapart fois ci ce sont les pas
l'intérêt des mesures jeudi leur garde
cette envie dans le mouvement mais moi
je vous regarde pas c'est pareil
c'est un apéritif quoi c'est comme si tu
viens de bouffer un tiramisu et puis la
honte à porte
en trois heures des pick-ups
saleh ouais c'est après
michel s'en fout complètement ce
tiramisu pic
alors il veut il veut ça donc j'imagine
que ding a essayé d'intercepter
ces mois à barinas bah je sais pas
accueillir ça vous dit j'ai mis un tweet
as a joué à 20 heures normalement déjà
19 heures la durée lessard et ouais
mais ça aura lieu jeudi prochain de
toute façon je pouvais pas la faire le
24 j'aurais pas été là
je pars pour la triche comme à amsterdam
tu as dû rencontrerait des gens là-bas
d'ailleurs de la commune
c'est le double dames et la finale
messieurs de roland garros maintenant le
double dames ya un an je
peux regarder ce soir qui gagne là c'est
ça pas dangereux tout ce qui fit ce
second mais normalement on s'en fout
enfin
vous êtes obligé de hausse mais on est
obligé mais bon moi je suis toujours
fait le choix de la sincérité surtout
les stream en fait on peut pas vous
vendre un suspense ou un truc
intéressant quand il n'y a plus rien
s'est fait passé comme la ligue 1 comme
paria 1000 points d'avancé tu regardes
leur match contre une autre équipe qui
joue pour plus rien mais enfin
ça c'est bien pour lui que pour le
supporter tu regardes tu es content
s'ils ratent leur corps but m'a charmé
les trucs accessoires contre est ce
qu'un match dure 90 minutes fab si
l'image heures et 6 heures où ça
non mais oui mais si la partie était
terminée demain tu viens tu te situes
regard d'une heure de jeu ça va mais au
lieu de ça à chaque fois six heures
quand même
quinze à vingt
bons joueurs d'échecs suisse bat à des
grands maîtres en suisse oui on a
eu tout d'abord dans les jeunes yannick
pelletier takhar shah qui était suisse
mon lit plat
t'as pas mal de emi
ça joue sajou en suisse lance pas un
énorme pays des chèques mais message où
il
affiche n'est pas qu'un scène
l'enthousiasmé sûrement personne à après
ben c'est drôle on leur montre
pas ce que je veux dire c'est que des
fois t'es des matches j'en ai plusieurs
fins par cards off karzaï 78 80 et avait
déjà fini qu'on est à 74 je sais pas
j'étais pas nés à l'époque je peux
constater reçu mais
voilà quoi
du coup il faut combler les anecdotes
perso des joueurs comme sur la télé oui
mais le problème c'est qu'à la télé ils
commandent pas des trucs aussi l'ont
enfin faut juste comprendre qu'en fait
on peut pas faire comme à la télé parce
que la télé en fait comme un truc est
finie ça va durer encore une demi heure
20 minutes 38 de plus à dire pas 18h en
fait c'est ça n'existe pas en fait se
forme à la télé c'est justement pour ça
que les échecs ne peuvent pas passer à
la télé parce que ce format ne peut pas
exister on détient plus d'anecdotes ya
plus rien en fait tout a déjà été dit
c'est mais bon au passage bravo à l'epo
d'avoir fait ça enfin tout le mérite
leur en revient bien sûr on n'est pas
désabusé de donner pouvoir lui lit bravo
le tour de france mais le tour de france
il ya des belles images si tu peux pas
comparer le tour de france avec fin vite
à chaque fois une victoire d'étape et le
maillot vert damian poids de taper un
objectif différent ils vivent ces beaux
kwata les petites histoires machin et
puis c'est pas les mêmes budgets de
retransmission ils te font d'airport
afin à l'intérieur du tour de france
quand il commet il ya des reportages qui
ont été tournées l'interview d'êtres
humains capsule d'interviewer tout ça
c'est complètement différent c'est pas
comparable et puis le tour de france
passait juste beau en fait c'est le tour
de france mais aussi femme
autour de la france voilà pas mais juste
façon ça se voit visuellement que
l'acteur de france est le nom d'une
personne que ça draine bah oui quand
bien même école à 10 minutes d'avancé
t'aurais des millions de gens sur le
bord de la route quand même la tâche 0
personnes qui viennent voir le tournoi
mais demain on regardera on va suivre le
tour le prologue c'est demain effet il y
en a eu 30 à huy en fait c'était
ironique aux lèvres désolé en déballant
mais quand vous faites de l'ironie en
fait n'hésitez pas à mettre un cap à ça
permet de comprendre ouais
le cas pas en fait et signe d'ironie
küng bisset guerre premier maillot jaune
à leh keen games j'aime bien que tu
avais pas de l'italien ben est bon
blasé aucune il est sympa il est suisse
et roule fort
si jamais le cap en mettant un cas pas
avec l'équipe fdj qui grattent tous ses
adversaires au lalalalalala
ça envoie à des blagues
mais c'est vrai que demain on pourra se
mettre le tout en font ouais
le prologue
prologue à dead coiffe en sus de tours
ont fait bonne chez scapa
mâchonne
c'est quand même bien dommage de tirer
vers le bas les échecs avec des formats
aussi peu intéressant moi j'en ai parlé
les amis
en janvier 2021 donc ça fait un an et il
ya un an et demi j'ai dit sur la chaîne
les gens qui regardent la chaîne souvent
son témoin que les échecs s'ils ne font
pas ce changement ils vont autodétruire
leur hype et que on va se tirer une
balle dans le pied si on est dans
l'immobilisme et qu'on va perdre
absolument toute la hype qui a pu être
apportée pour encore 20 ans je les dis
j'ai prévenu ça se vérifie
1 je suis pas content d'avoir raison là
dessus parce que ça me pénalise mois
mais il se trouve que j'avais prévu le
truc et que c'était visible qu'ils
allaient détruire la hype et qu'ils
allaient dégoûter les gens d échec après
on a besoin d'une scène de haut niveau
moi j'ai plein de potes qui sont mis à
suivre les les échecs et qui viennent
plus voir les tournois parce qu'ils ont
fait c'est jamais intéressant mais sur
alsabki un très bon ami avec qui on
s'entend très bien il a même pas un fan
jam a écrit mon espace pas aux candidats
et tous mais fait il passe même plus
parce qu'il sait que c'est ça en fait
mais c'est non mais c'est elle c'est que
les gens ils ont intégré que ce que
notre scène de haut niveau c'était de la
merde non mais c'est grave quand même
d'en être arrivé à ce point là et ils
ont raison et à chaillevois du combat
oui mais du coup ils passent plus mes où
vous avez raison enfin d'une façon
écoutant déçu c'est en fait je crois que
le match de carlson n'est postale avait
achevé et là dessus il m'a juste et
qu'une violence c'est la même merde non
[Rires]
merci à petits et grands tous les partis
ont été intéressantes la plupart du
temps
mais le niveau de jeu était pas mal lu
des parties intéressantes mais en fait
le format fait cap à la hype il n'ya pas
le suspense il n'y a pas le climax qui
arrive à la fin t'as pas la contrebande
entre les deux titans et donc oui le
format et mal pensée pour pour être
compréhensible et
pas publics et
facile à suivre l'entraînement quoi
bah oui
je me souviens de gens qui étaient
arrivés par le haut niveau ils ont vu
des tournois ils sont dix ont disparu
bahar et non mais après bon autant
ça qui est pas mal de gens qui
lisent leurs premiers championnats du
monde car le cngpo qui sont dit ok c'est
du gros truc est en fait on dit ouais
c'est ça le gros truc
en fait là de six heures par jour du nul
d'un coup ça gagne c'est in fine c'est
yannick bombe of carnage tu dis
qu'est-ce que j'ai arrêté pendant trois
semaines
et je comprends c'est alors après on a
récupéré avec chance sur la fin quelques
personnes avec champion du monde de
beats et rapide qui était vraiment
emballé qui on dirait c'était super et
tout
mais malheureusement je peux comprendre
après rennes et l'om c'est qu'en fait
ils ont du mal à revenir sur les tons
intéressant parce qu'en fait comme 9 3
sur 10 sont inintéressants au bout d'un
moment juste survient plus d'infos
bientôt mais on va devoir la chance
à chaque sont pas adaptés à ceux des
spectacles hors presse et pas que du
spectacle ce raid est vrai tournant on
n'invente pas de faire semblant de son
monde et des life mais faudrait que le
format c'est un peu juste là à faire un
format coup pour finir à la fin sur une
finale entre deux hommes tu vois de
pâques c'est pas fini trois jours avant
la fin rien que des petits détails comme
ça parce que tu vois j'ai des potes je
reprends je reprends sable comme exemple
finir indûment les âmes en fait tu lui
écris tu y as well un les restes de
trois parties c'est la fin demain
monsieur va au moins passer à la fin
quant à des gens aussi comme beaucoup tu
regarde pas trop le tennis tu regardes
la finale nous verse apple on regarde
pas trop à l'efs on a regardé vers sabha
deux derniers grands prix -y compris
machin tu reviens plus du coup tu
t'intéresses un peu la saison d'après
thüga obtient lui l'a gagné questionné
mais là en fait le truc c'est que t'as
même pas ça
donc c'est même pas car dans ce déjà la
cadence enlevé les honneurs de rage ou
au 40e maîtres que 38 ce serait mieux
mais c'est même pas que ça c'est en fait
juste déjà dans un truc ou à la fin ça
peut un peu joué
après évidemment si tu faisais un
circuit rapide et en longue il ya un
vrai circuit rapide et que pouvait
traîner un peu plus de repos rapide qui
rapporterait de la rive sur le long du
coup ce serait bénéfique pour le long
aussi mais bon là c'est déjà trop
demander mais ouais c'est dommage
non mais tu pourrais faire un peu
de tournois comme c'est la saison de
rugby quoi je suis un tendre a du coup
même que le tournage soit la saison
régulière et à la fin de fait le
play-off non mais en plus tu as sur les
candidats il se trouve que l'on peut
même pas nous prendre l'argument de dire
ah c'est pas les traditions des échecs
ou quoi parce qu'en fait les matchs au
cours de l'histoire des échecs c'est
juste la tradition c'est plus un jeu de
match c'est logique puisque c'est un
c'est un combat les échecs et les
combats c'est des duels de doma mais moi
je trouve que c'est assez logique en
fait
ils veulent limiter à 20 ans ce maximum
mais tu dois quand même mais tu l'a
quand même en fait et puis en fait s'ils
veulent imiter la variance battu donne
le faire alors tu fais plus de parti hu
est en fait 28 5 ans ça veut dire tu
vois tu fais un vrai truc quoi tu
l'aimais drame ont bien
hâte à l'état les bras 4 comme ils
disent en double élimination qui sont
pas mal tu perds un match mais tu repars
dans le loser bracket et tu peux revenir
ça c'est pour limiter un peu la variance
sympa tu as plein de solutions on peut
importe
thèse d'un départ match ben oui quatre
parties entre deux hommes et puis en
faire huit pour la finale ou si si
souvent quand tu trouveras un truc même
4 savoir en fait m
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font exactement ce
qu'on soit ça reste des échecs mari mais
les échecs c'est bien ça cher
s'intéresse à le jeu en lui-même on vous
dit pas que les partis sont nuls on n'a
pas dit d'ailleurs les partis d
intéressante et c'est le format du
tournoi de choses différentes on va pas
réformé de jeu à faire des tours qui
fera vers les pions je sais pas quoi
appuyer image qu il forme un couple sont
plus agréables à regarder bah oui la
coupe du monde d'échecs c'était très
sympa on avait vraiment beaucoup bien
qui fait
qu'ils aient en quarts 8e car carter
sur qui sera face à ces régions ce
serait que ça serait cool alors que oui
tu viens samedi du coup spice boy girl
au au blind test
espagole jeune âgé de 25 ans je ne sais
pas si si laura
rfc paraît que c'est un peu de chance on
est 80 90 ou 2000 fait un peu jeune star
de la chanson française je vais être jeu
debout mais bon si on met du rock
anglais
avec l'ina ont découvert donc je pense
qu'on couvre un peu mais c'est que la
radiothérapie monde eh bien oui
c'est vrai mais c'est bon pour les
chansons françaises en fait
où
il ya porquerolles assez joli parfois
porquerolles fantastique